the following is a conversation with lee
cronin a chemist from university of
glasgow who's one of the most
fascinating brilliant out-of-the-box
thinking scientists i've ever spoken to
this episode was recorded more than two
weeks ago so the war in ukraine is not
mentioned
i have been spending a lot of time each
day talking to people in ukraine and
russia
i have family friends colleagues and
loved ones
in both countries
i will try to release a solo episode on
this war but i've been failing to find
the words that make sense of it for
myself
and others
so i may not
i ask for your understanding no matter
which path i take
most of my time is spent trying to help
as much as i can privately
i'm talking to people who are suffering
who are angry afraid
when i returned to this conversation
with lee
i couldn't help but smile
he's a beautiful brilliant and hilarious
human being
he's basically a human manifestation of
the mad scientist rig sanchez from rick
and morty
i thought about quitting this podcast
for a time
but for now at least i'll keep going
i love people too much
you the listener
i meet folks on the street or when i run
you say a few kind words about the
podcast and we talk about life the small
things and the big things
all of it gives me hope
people are just amazing you are amazing
i ask for your support wisdom and
patience as i keep going
with this silly little podcast
including through some difficult
conversations
and hopefully
many fascinating and fun ones too
this is a lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now to your
friends
here's lee
cronin
how do you think life originated on
earth and what insights does that give
us about life
if we go back to the origin of earth and
you think about maybe 4.7 4.6 4.5
billion years ago planet was quite hot
there was a limited number of minerals
there was some carbon some water and i
think that maybe it's a really simple
set of chemistry that we we really don't
understand
so that means you've got a finite number
of elements that are going to react very
simply with one another
and out of that mess comes a cell so
literally sand turns into cells and it
seems to happen quick
so what i think i can say with some
degree of
i think not certainty but curiosity
genuine curiosity is that life happened
fast yeah so when we say fast
this is a pretty surprising
fact and maybe you can actually correct
me and elaborate but it seems like most
like 70 or 80 percent of the time that
earth has been around there's been life
on it like some very significant
percentage so when you say fast like the
slow part is from single cell
or from bacteria to some more
complicated organism it seems like most
of the time that earth has been around
it's been single cell
or like very basic organisms like a
couple billion years but yeah you're
right that that's really i recently kind
of revisited
our history and saw this
and
i was just looking at the timeline wait
a minute like how did life just spring
up so quickly like really quickly that
makes me think
that it really wanted to like
put another way it's very easy for life
to spring yeah i agree i think it's much
more inevitable and i think um i try to
kind of not provoke but try and push
chemists to think about because chemists
are part are central to this problem
right
of understanding the origin of life on
earth at least because we're made of
made of chemistry but i wonder if the
origin of life
on a planet or so the emergence of life
on the planet is as
common as the formation of a star
and if you start framing it in that way
it allows you to then look at the
universe slightly differently because
um and we can get into this i think in
quite some detail but i think i to to
come back to your question i have
little idea of how life got started but
i know it was simple
and i know that the process of selection
had to occur before
the biology was established so that
selection
built the framework from which life
kind of grew in complexity and
capability and functionality and
autonomy and i think these are all
really important words that we can
unpack over the next
while can you say all the words again so
he says selection
so natural selection
eight the original a b testing and so
and then complexity
and then or the degree of autonomy and
sophistication because i think that
people misunderstand what life is um
some people say that life is a cell and
some people that say that life is a
a virus or life is a you know an on off
switch
i don't think it's that life is the
universe developing a memory
and the laws of physics and the way well
there are no laws of physics physics is
just memory free stuff
right
there's only a finite number of ways you
can arrange the fundamental particles to
do the things life is the universe
developing
a memory so it's like
sewing
a piece of art slowly
and then you can look back at it so
so there's a stickiness to life it's
like universe doing stuff
and when you say memory it's like
there's a stickiness to a bunch of the
stuff that's building together yeah so
like you can
in a stable way like uh
trace back the complexity
and that tells a coherent story yeah and
i think yeah okay
that's by the way very poetic
and beautiful
life is the universe developing a memory
[Music]
okay and then there's autonomy you said
complexity we'll talk about but
it's a really interesting idea that
selection preceded biology
yeah i think yes so what first of all
what is chemistry
like does sand still count as chemistry
sure i mean as a chemist they can't
carry a chemist if i'm allowed a card i
don't know i don't know what i am most
days what is the card made of
what's the chemical composition of the
card
yeah so um what is chemistry well
chemistry is the thing that happens when
you bring electrons together and you
form bonds
so bonds well i say to people when they
talk about life elsewhere
and i just say well there's bonds
there's hope because bonds allow you to
get heterogeneity they allow you to
record those memories or at least on
earth um you could imagine uh
you know a stannis left lemtrey world
where you might have life emerging or
intelligence emerging before life that
may be something to on like solaris or
something but you know to get to
selection if you can form if atoms can
combine and form bonds
those bonds uh those atoms can bond to
different elements and those and those
molecules
will have different identities and
interact with each other differently and
then you can start to have some degree
of causation or interaction
and then selection and then put and then
existence
and then you you you go you go up the
kind of the path of complexity and so at
least on earth
as we know it there are there is a
sufficient pool of
available chemicals to start create
searching that combinatorial space of
bonds
so okay this is a really interesting
question let's let's lay it out so bonds
almost like cards we say there's bonds
there is uh
life there's intelligence there's
consciousness and what you just made me
realize
is um
those can emerge or let's put bonds
aside uh those can emerge in any order
that's that's really brilliant so
intelligence can come before life it's
like
pan psychists believe that consciousness
com i guess comes before
life
and before intelligence
so consciousness like permeates all
matter it's some kind of fabric of
reality okay so like within this
framework you can kind of arrange
everything but you need to have the
bonds
um that's precedes everything else oh
and the other thing is selection
so like the mechanism of selection
that could
uh proceed see couldn't that proceed
bonds to whatever the house election so
i would say that there is an elegant
order to it that bonds
allow selection allows the emergence of
life allows the emergence of
multicellularity and then
more information processing building
state machines all the way up however
you could imagine a situation if you had
um i don't know a neutron star or a sun
or a ferromagnetic loops interacting
with one another
and these oscillators building state
machines and these state machines
reading something out in the environment
over time these state machines would be
able to
literally record what happened in the
past and sense what's going on in the
present and imagine the future however i
don't think it's ever going to be with
within a human comprehension that type
of life
um i wouldn't count it out because um
you know whenever you i know in science
whenever i say something's impossible i
then wake up the next day and say no
that's actually wrong i mean there are
there are some limits of course um i
don't see myself traveling fast and
light any time soon but eric weinstein
says that's possible so he will say
europe sure but i'm an experimentalist
as well so one of my i have two super
powers and my
stupidity and i don't mean that is a you
know i'm like absolutely completely
witless but i mean my ability to kind of
just start again and ask the question
and then do it with an experiment i
always wanted to be a theoretician
growing up but i just didn't have the
just didn't have the intellectual
capability but i i was able to think of
experiments in my head i could then do
in my lab or in that you know when i was
a with a child
outside and then those experiments in my
head and then outside reinforce one
another so i think that's a very good
way of kind of
grounding the science right well that's
the nice way to think about
theoreticians is they're just
people who run experiments in their head
i mean that's exactly what einstein did
right and but you were also capable of
doing that in the head
in your head inside your head and in the
real world and the connection between
the two
is when you first discovered your
superpower stupidity
i like it okay what's your second
superpower oh your accent or
it's that well i don't know i'm my i
like i am genuinely curious so my
curious so i have a you know like
everybody ego problems but my curiosity
is bigger than my ego so as long as that
happens i i can i can that's awesome
that is so powerful you're just dropping
some powerful lines so curiosity
is bigger than ego that's something i
have to think about because you always
struggle about the role of ego in life
and
um
that's
that's so nice to think about
don't think about the size of ego the
absolute size of ego think about the
relative size of ego to the other the
other horses pulling at you and if the
curiosity one is bigger then uh ego will
do just fine and make you uh fun to talk
to anyway so those are the two
superpowers how do those connect to
natural selection or in selection and
bonds and
i forgot already life and consciousness
so that we're going back to selection in
the universe and origin of life on earth
i mean um selection has a for i'm
convinced that selection is a force in
the universe not me not a fundamental
force but a but a directing but it is a
directing force because existence
although
um existence appears to be the default
um the existence of what why does
um we can get to this later i think but
it's amazing that
the discreet things exist
and you know you see this cup it's not
the you know sexiest cup in the world
but it's pretty functional this cup um
the complexity of this cup isn't just in
the object it is literally the lineage
of people making cups and recognizing
that seeing that in their head making an
abstraction of a cup and then making a
different one
so
i wonder how many billions of cups
have you know come before this one and
that's the process of selection and
existence and the only reason the cup is
still used is quite useful i like the
handle you know it's convenient so i
don't die i keep hydration um and so
i think we are missing something
fundamental in the universe about
selection and i think what biology is is
a is a selection
amplifier
and that the this is where autonomy
comes in and actually i think that how
humanity is going to humans and
and autonomous robots or whatever we're
going to call them in the future we'll
we'll supercharge that even further so
selection is happening in the universe
but if you look in the asteroid belt
selection if objects are being kicked in
and out the asteroid belt um those
trajectories are quite complex you don't
really look at that as productive
selection because it's not doing
anything to improve its function but is
it the
asteroid belt has existed for some time
so there is some selection going on but
the functionality is is somewhat limited
on earth
at the formation of earth
interaction of chemicals and molecules
in the environment gave selection and
then things could happen because you
could think about in chemistry we could
have an infinite number of reactions
happen but they don't all all the
reactions are allowed to happen don't
happen why because they're energy
barriers
so
there must be some things called
catalysts out there or
there are bits of minerals that when two
molecules get together in that mineral
it lowers the energy barrier for the
reaction and so the reaction is is
promoted so suddenly you get one
reaction over another
series of possibilities occurring that
makes a particular molecule and this
keeps happening in steps and before you
know it these almost these waves as
discrete reactions work together and you
start to build
a machinery
that that that is run by existence
so
as you you go forward in time the fact
that the molecules
the bonds are getting there are more
bonds in a molecule there's more
function there's more capability for
this molecule to interact with other
molecules to redirect them it's like a
series of little and i don't want to use
this term
too much but it's almost thinking about
the the simplest von neumann constructor
that's the simplest molecule that could
build a more complicated molecule to
build a more complicated molecule and
before you know it when that more
complicated molecule can act on the
causal chain that's produced itself
and change it suddenly you start to get
towards some kind of autonomy and that's
where life i think emerges in earnest
every single word in in the past few
paragraphs let's uh break those apart
but
uh who's von neumann what's the
constructor
the closing of the loop that you're
talking about
uh the the molecule that starts becoming
the i think you said like the smallest
flying neumann constructor yeah the
smallest the minimal so uh what do all
those things mean and what is uh
uh what are we supposed to imagine when
we think about the smallest uh violent
constructor so
john von neumann is a real hero actually
if not just me but many people i think
computer science and and physics
he was an incredible intellect
he probably solved a lot of the problems
that we're working on today and just
forgot to write them down yeah
and
i'm not sure if it's john von neumann or
johnny as i think his friends called him
but as um
i think he was hungarian
mathematician came to the us
and um basically got was involved in the
manhattan project and developing
computation
and um came up with all sorts of ideas
and i think it was one of the first
people to come come up with cellular
automata
and but he really i didn't know this
little fact i think i think so and i
think well anyway if he didn't come up
with it he probably did come up with and
didn't write it down there was a couple
of people did at the same time and then
conway obviously took it on and then
wolfram
loves cas there is his fabric of the
universe
and what i think he imagined was that
he wasn't satisfied and this may be
incorrect recollection but there's so a
lot of what i say is going to be kind of
you know
just way out of my uh
you're just part of the universe
um creating its memory designing exactly
yeah rewriting history rewriting exactly
imperfectly so but what i mean is i
think he he would he liked this idea of
thinking about
um
how could a
turing machine literally build itself
without a turing machine right it's like
literally how did state machines emerge
and i think that von neumann
constructors he was wanted to conceive
of a minimal thing
autonomous
that could build itself and what would
those rules look like in the world and
that's what a von neumann kind of
constructor looked like like it's a
minimal hypothetical object that could
build itself self-replicate
and um
and i'm really fascinated by that
because i think that
um although it's probably not
exactly what happened
um it's a nice model because as chemists
if we could go back to the origin of
life and think about what is a minimal
machine
that can get structured randomly so like
with no prime mover we've no we've no no
architect
and it assembles through just existence
so random stuff bumping in together and
you make this first molecule so you have
molecule a
and molecule a um interacts with another
random molecule b and they get together
and they realize by working together
they can make more of themselves
but then they realize they can mutate so
they can make a b prime so a b prime is
different to a b
and then a b prime
can then act back where a and b were
being created and slightly nudge that
causal chain
and
make a b prime
more
um evolvable or learn more so that's the
closing the loop part closing the loop
part got it it feels like the mutation
part
is um
not that difficult it feels like the
difficult part is just creating a copy
of yourself that's step one it seems uh
um
that seems like one of the greatest
inventions in the history of the
universe is the
the first molecule they figured out holy
[ __ ] i can create a copy of myself
how
hard is that i think it's really really
easy
okay i did not expect that i think it's
really really easy well let's take a
step back
i think replication replicating
molecules are rare but if you say you
know i think i was saying on i probably
got into trouble on twitter the other
day so i was trying to write this
there's about more than 18 mils of water
in there so one mole of water 6.022
times 10 to the 23
molecules that's about the number of
stars in the universe i think of the
order so there's three universe worth
but between somebody corrected you on
twitter yeah i'm as if i've always been
corrected it's a great fact but but
there's a lot of molecules in the water
yeah and so and so there's a lot of so
although it's for you and me really hard
to conceive of if existence is not
the default for a long period of time
because what happens is the molecules
get degraded so so much of the
possibilities in the universe are just
broken back into atoms so you have this
this kind of
destruction of the molecules for our
chemical reactions
so you only need one or two molecules to
become good at copying themselves for
them suddenly to then take resources in
the pool and start to grow and so then
replication actually over time when you
have bonds i think is
much simpler and much easier
and i even found this in my lab years
ago i had one of the reasons i started
doing inorganic chemistry and making
rust making a bit of rust based on a
thing called molybdenum military oxide
is this molybdenum oxide
it's very simple
but when you add acid to it and some
electrons they make these molecules you
just cannot possibly imagine um would be
constructed big gigantic wheels of 154
molybdenum atoms in a wheel or i cost a
dodecahedron 132 molybdenum atoms all in
the same pot and i realized when i and i
just finished experiments two years ago
i've just published a couple of papers
on this that they're actually
there is a random small molecule with 12
atoms in it that can form randomly but
it happens to template its own
production
and then by chance it templates the ring
just an accident just like just an
absolute accident and that ring also
helps make
the small
12 mer and so you have what's called an
auto catalytic set
where a
makes b
and b helps make a
and and vice versa and you then make
this loop so it's a bit like um
these they all work in in synergy to
make this chain of events that grow
and it doesn't take um a very
sophisticated model to show that
if you have these objects are competing
and then collaborating to help one
another build they just grow out of the
mess and although they seem improbable
they are improbable in fact impossible
in one step
there's multiple steps this is when the
blind people look at the blind
watchmaker argument when you talk about
how could a watch something
spontaneously emerge well it doesn't
it's a lineage of watchers and cruder
devices that that that couple are
bootstrapped onto one another
right
uh
so it's very improbable but once you get
that little discovery like with the
wheel
and um
fire it just gets
explodes in because it's so successful
it explodes it's basically
selection so this templating mechanism
that allows you to have a little like
blueprint for yourself how you go
through different procedures is to build
copies of yourself
so i uh in chemistry somehow it's
possible to imagine that that kind of
thing
is easy to spring up
in more complex organisms it feels like
a different thing and much more
complicated like
we're having like uh
multiple abstractions of the birds and
the bees conversation here but with with
human inside with complex organisms it
feels like difficult to have
reproduction
uh
to uh
that's gonna get clipped out i'm gonna
make fun of that um
uh it's still it's difficult to develop
this idea of making copies of yourself
or no
uh because that seems like a magical
idea for life
to uh
wow
that feels like very necessary for what
selection is for what evolution is but
then if selection precedes all this
then maybe these are just like echoes
of the selection the selecting mechanism
at different scales yeah that's exactly
it so selection is the default in the
universe if you want to
and what happens is that life
the solution that that life has got on
earth life on earth biology on earth
um is unique to earth we can talk about
that um
and that was really hard fought for but
that was that is the solution that works
on earth the ribosome the fundamental
machine that is responsible for every
life for you know every cell on earth of
whatever wherever it is in the in the
kingdom of life
that is an incredibly complex object but
it was evolved over time and it wasn't
involved in a vacuum and i think that
once we understand that selection
can um
occur
um without the ribosome but what the
ribosome does it's a phase transition in
replication
and i think that that and also
technology that that is uh um
probably much easier to get to than we
think
why why do you put
the ribosome as the central
um
part of living organisms on earth it
basically is a combination of two
different polymer systems so rna and
peptides so the rna world if you like
gets transmitted and builds proteins and
the proteins are responsible for all the
catalysis it will the majority of the
catalysis that goes on the cell no
ribosome no proteins no decoding
no evolution so ribosome is looking at
the action so you don't put like the rna
itself as the critical thing like
information you put action as the most
important thing i think the actual
molecules that we have in biology right
now entirely contingent on the history
of life on earth they could there are so
many possible solutions and this is
where chemistry got itself into origin
of life chemistry gets itself into a bit
of a trap yeah let me uh interrupt you
there you've tweeted you're gonna get
i'm i'm gonna cite your tweets like it's
shakespeare okay
it's surprising you haven't gotten
cancelled on twitter yet um it's your
brilliance once again saves you um i'm
just kidding there's there's uh uh you
like to have a little bit of fun on
twitter you've tweeted that quote origin
of life research is a scam
so if this is shakespeare can we analyze
this word why why is the origin of life
research a scam aren't you kind of doing
origin of life research
um
okay it was tongue-in-cheek but yeah i
think and i meant it as tongue-in-cheek
um i am i'm not doing or i'm not doing
the origin of life research i'm trying
to make artificial life
and i also want to to bound the
likelihood of mate of the origin of life
on earth but more importantly to find
origin of life elsewhere but let me
directly address the tweet there are
many many good chemists out there doing
origin of life research but i want to
nudge them and i think they're brilliant
like there's no there's there's no
question
the chemistry they are doing their
motivation is great
so what i meant by that tweet is saying
that maybe they're making assumptions
about saying if only
i could make this particular type of
molecule say this rna molecule or this
phosphodiester or this other molecule
it's going to somehow unlock the origin
of life
and i think that origin of life has been
looking at this for a very long time and
whilst i i think it's brilliant to
work out how you can get to those
molecules i think that chemistry and
chemists doing origin of life could
be nudged into doing something even more
profound and and so the argument i'm
making it's a bit like right now let's
say i don't know the first tesla that
makes its way to
i don't know into a new country in the
world let's say i
let's say there's country x that has
never had a tesla before and they get
the tesla russia
and they take the test and what they do
is they take the tests for a part and
say we want to find the origin of of
cars in the universe and say okay how
did this form and how did this fall
and they just randomly keep making until
they make the door they make the wheel
they make the steering column and all
this stuff and
and they say oh that's the route that's
the way uh that's the way cars emerge on
earth but actually we know that there's
a causal chain of cars going right back
to henry ford and the horse and carriage
and before that maybe you know um
where people were using wheels and and i
think that
obsession with the identities that we
see in biology right now are giving us a
false sense of
security about what we're looking for
and i think the origin of life chemistry
is in danger
of
of not making the progress that it
deserves because the chemists are doing
this is this the field is exploding
right now there's amazing people out
there young and old doing this and
there's deservedly so more money going
in you know i used to complain there's
more money being spent searching for the
higgs boson that we know exists and the
origin of life
you know why is that the origin we
understand the origin of life we're
going to actually work out what life is
and we're going to be outbound the
likelihood of finding life elsewhere in
the universe and most important for us
we are going to know
or have a good idea what the future of
humanity looks like you know we need to
understand that although we're precious
we're not the only life forms in the
universe well that's my very strong
impression i have no data for that it's
just right now a belief and i want to
turn that belief into a more than a
belief by by experimentation
but i coming back to the scam the scam
is if we just make this rna we've we've
got this you know this uh
this fluke event we know how that's
simple
let's make this phosphodiester or let's
make atp or adp we've got that part
nailed let's now make this other
molecule another molecule and how many
molecules are going to be enough and
then
the reason i say this is when you go
back to craig venter
when
he invented
his life forms india
um this micro this this minimal plasmid
it's a it's a myoplasma something i
don't know the name of it but he made
this wonderful um cell and said i've
i've invented life
not quite he facsimiled the genome from
this entity and made it in the lab all
the dna but he didn't make the cell he
had to take an existing cell
that has a causal chain going all the
way back to luca and he showed when he
took out the gene the genes and put in
his genes synthesized the cell could
boot up but it's remarkable that he
could not make a cell from scratch and
even now today synthetic biologists
cannot make a cell from scratch
because there's some contingent
information embodied outside the genome
in the cell
and that is just incredible
so there's lots of layers to the scam
well let me then ask
the question how can we create life in
the lab from scratch
what have been the most promising
attempts at creating life in the lab
from scratch has anyone actually been
able to do it do you think anyone will
be able to do it in the near future if
they haven't already
um can yeah i think that um nobody has
made life in the lab from scratch lots
of people would argue that they have
made progress the craig vent i think the
synthesis of a synthetic genome
milestone in human uh achievement
brilliant yeah can we just walk back and
say
what
uh
would you say from your perspective one
of the world experts in exactly this
area
what does it mean to create life from
scratch where if you sit back whether
you do it or somebody else does it it's
like
damn
this is we just created life
um well what i would i can tell you what
i would expect i would like to be able
to do
is to
go from sand to cells in my lab
and
and can you explain what sand is you
just in organic just in organic stuff
like like like basically just so sand
it's just silica silicon oxide with some
other ions in it maybe some inorganic
carbon some carbonates
just basically clearly dead stuff you
you could just grind rocks into sand and
it would be what in like in a vacuum so
they could remove anything else that
could possibly
uh
be uh
like a shadow of life that can assist in
the chemical you could do that you could
insist and say look i'm going to take
and not just inorganic i want some more
i want to cheat and have some organic
but i want inorganic organic and i'll
explain the play on words in a moment so
i would like to basically put into a
world let's say a completely
you know a synthetic world if you like a
closed world
put some inorganic materials and just
literally add some energy in some form
be it lightning or heat
uv light
and run this thing in cycles
over time and let it solve the search
problem so
i see the origin of life as a search
problem in chemical space
and then i would wait literally wait for
a life form to crawl out the test tube
that's the joke i tell my group
literally wait uh uh for a very and
don't worry it's gonna be very feeble
it's not gonna take over the world you
know there's ways of ethically
containing his last words
it was indeed indeed indeed but i i i
you know this is being recorded right
it'll make you
it will not make you look good once it
crawls out of the lab and destroys all
of human civilization but yes but there
is very good there's a very good things
you can do to prevent that yeah for
instance if you put stuff in your world
which isn't earth abundant so let's say
we make life based on molybdenum and it
escapes it would die immediately because
there's not enough molybdenum in the
environment so we can put in we can we
can do it we can do responsible life or
as i fantasize with my research group on
our away day that would go in it's you
know i think it's actually
morally
we if life if we don't find if you met
until humanity finds life in the
universe this is going on a tangent it's
our moral obligation to make origin of
life bombs identify dead planets and
bomb them with our origin of life
machines and make them alive i think it
is our moral obligation to do that
i'm sure some people might argue with me
about that but i think that we need a
lot more life in the universe and then
we kind of forget we
we did it and then come back
and then say where did you come from but
coming back to the what i'd expect so
let's just say are there
are you back it's i think this is once
again a rick and morty episode
definitely it's definitely all rick and
morty all the way down so we i imagine
we have this pristine
um experiment and everything is you know
sanitized and we put in inorganic
materials and we we have cycles with
them day night cycles up down whatever
and we
look for evidence of replication and
evolution over time and that's what the
experiment should be now are there
people doing this in the world right now
there are a couple of there's some
really good groups doing this there's
some really interesting scientists doing
this around the world
they're kind of
perhaps
too much associated with the scam
so
and
and so they're using molecules
that are already we're already invented
by biology so there's a bit of
replication built in
um but i still think the work that is
doing they're doing is amazing um but i
would like people to be a bit freer and
say let's just basically shake a load of
sand in a box and wait for life to come
out because that's what happened on
earth and so that we have to understand
that now how would i know i've been
successful well because i'm not
obsessing with
what molecules are in life
now i i would wager a vast quantity of
money um i'm not very rich so just be a
few dollars but for me
um
the the the solution space will be
different
so the the genetic material will be not
rna
the proteins will not be what we think
they'll it would the solutions will be
just completely different and it might
be and it'll be very feeble because
that's the other thing we should be able
to show
um fairly robustly that even if i did
make or someone did make a new life form
in the lab it would be so poor
that it's not going to leap out it is
the the fear about making a lethal life
form
in the lab from scratch is um
similar to us imagining that we're going
to make the terminator uh boston
dynamics tomorrow yeah simply not you
and and i and the problem is we don't
communicate that properly i know you
yourself very um you explain this very
well you know there is not the ai
catastrophe coming
um we're very far away from that that
doesn't mean we should ignore it same
with the origin of life catastrophe it's
not coming anytime soon we shouldn't
ignore it but we shouldn't let that fear
stop us from doing those experiments but
this is a much much longer discussion
because there's a lot of details there i
would say there is potential for
catastrophic events
to happen
in much dumber ways within in ai space
there's a lot of ways to create like uh
social networks that are creating a kind
of uh accelerated
set of events that we might not be able
to control the
social network virality in the digital
space
can create
mass movements of ideas that can then if
times are tough
create military conflict and all those
kinds of things but that's not intel
super intelligent ai
that's an interesting
at scale application of ai and if you
look at viruses viruses are pretty dumb
but at scale their application is pretty
detrimental and so origin of life much
like
all the kind of virology you know
um
the very contentious word of gain of
function research and virology sort of
like research on viruses
uh
messing with them
genetically that can create a lot of
problems if not done well so we have to
be very
cautious so there's a kind of whenever
you're ultra cautious about stuff
in ai or in virology and biology
it borders on cynicism i would say where
it's like everything we do is going to
turn out to be destructive and terrible
so i'm just going to sit here and do
nothing
okay that's a possible solution
except for the fact that somebody's
going to do it
it's
science and technology progresses
so we have to do it in an ethical way in
a good way considering in a transparent
way in an open way
considering
all the possible positive trajectories
that could be taken and making sure as
much as possible that we walk those
trajectories so yeah i don't think
terminator is coming but a totally
unexpected version of terminator
maybe around the corner yeah it might be
here already yeah so i agree with that
and so going back to the origin of life
discussion i think that in synthetic
biology right now
we have to be very careful about how we
edit genomes and edit synthetic biology
to do things so that's kind of that's
where things might go wrong in the same
way as you know twitter turning
ourselves into kind of
strange scale effects
i would love
origin of life research or artificial
life research to get to the point where
we have those worries
because that's why i think we're just so
far away from that we are ju you know
right now i think there are two really
important um angles there is the origin
of life people researchers who are
faithfully working on this
and trying to make those molecules the
scan molecules i talk about
and then there are people on the
creationist side who's saying look the
fact you can't make these molecules and
you can't make a cell means that um
evolution isn't true and all this other
stuff gotcha yeah and so and
i find that really frustrating because
actually the origin of life researchers
are all working in good faith right yes
and and so what i'm trying to do is give
origin of life research a little bit
more of a of a of an open
an open context and one of the things i
think is important um i really want to
make a new life form in my lifetime i
really want to prove that life
is a general phenomena a bit like
gravity in the universe because i think
that's going to be really important for
humanity's um
global
psychological state
meaning going forward that's beautifully
that's beautifully put so one it will
help us understand ourselves
so that's useful for science but two it
gives us
a kind of hope if not uh
an awe
at all the huge amounts of alien
civilizations that are out there if you
can build life
and understand just how easy it is to
build life
then that's just as good if not much
better than discovering life on another
planet yeah it's
i mean it's cheaper it's much cheaper
and much easier
and uh
probably much more conclusive because
once you're able to create life
like you said it's a search problem that
uh
there's probably a lot of different ways
to do it so once you create the once you
find the first solution
you probably have all the right
methodology for finding all kinds of
other solutions yeah and wouldn't it be
great if we could find a solution i mean
it's probably a bit late for
i mean i worry about climate change but
i'm not that worried about climate
change and i think what one day you
could think about
could we engineer a new type of life
form that could basically and i i don't
want to do this i don't think we should
do this necessarily but it's a good
thought experiment
that would perhaps take co2 out of the
atmosphere or or an intermediate life
form so it's not quite alive it's almost
like a like an add-on that we can with a
time
a time
dependent add-on you could give to say
cyanobacteria in the ocean or to maybe
to wheat and say right we're just going
to we're going to fix a bit more co2
and we're going to work how much we need
to fix to basically save the climate
and
and we're going to use evolutionary
principles to basically get there
what worries me is that biology has had
a few billion years to find a solution
for co2 fixation it hasn't really
done
it's not the solution isn't brilliant
for our needs but biology wasn't
thinking about our needs biology was
thinking about biology's needs
but i think if we can do as you say make
life in the lab
then suddenly we don't need to go to
everywhere and conclusively prove it i
think we make life in the lab we look at
the extent of life in the solar system
how far did earth life get probably were
all martians probably life got going on
mars the chemistry on mars seeded earth
that might have been a legitimate way to
kind of truncate the surface space
but in the outer solar system we might
have completely different life forms on
enceladus on europa um and and tyson and
that would be a cool thing because okay
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute
did you just say that you think in terms
of likelihood
life started on mar like uh
statistically speaking life started on
mars and seeded earth it could be
possible because life was like so mars
was habitable uh for the type of life
that we have right now type of chemistry
before earth so it seems to me that like
mars got searching doing chemistry
and started way before yeah and so they
had a few more replicators and some
other stuff and if those replicas got
ejected from mars and landed on earth
and earth would like
i don't need to start again right
thanks for that and then it just carries
on so i i'm not going i think there is
we will find evidence of life on mars
either life we put there by mistake
contamination or actually life the
earliest remnants of life
um and that would be really exciting
it's a really good reason to go there
but i think it's more unlikely because
the gravitational situation in the solar
system if we find life in the outer
solar system titan and all that that
would be its own thing exactly wow that
would be so cool if we go to mars and we
find life that looks a hell of a lot
similar to earth life and then we'll go
to uh
titan and all those weird moons with the
ices and the volcanoes and all that kind
of stuff and then we find there
something that looks
i don't know way weirder yeah some other
some non-rna type of in my situation
almost life like in the prebiotic
chemical space and i think there are
four types of exoplanets we can go look
for right because when jwst goes up and
touch wood it goes up and everything's
fine
when we look at a star we'll know
statistically most stars have planets
around them what type of planet are they
are they going to be dead
are they going to be
just a prebiotic origin of life coming
so are they going to be technological
and you know so with intelligence on
them and will they will they have died
so so you know from you know had life on
them but all the four states therefore
and so and suddenly it's a bit like i
want to classify planets the way we
classify stars yeah and i think that in
terms of their rather than having this
all we've found that we've found methane
there's evidence of life we've found
oxygen that's the evidence of life we
found whatever molecule marker
um and start to then start frame things
a little bit more but as those four
states yeah which by the way you're just
saying four but there could be a um
before the dead there could be other
states that we humans can't even
conceive
just prebiotic almost alive you know got
the possibility to come alive i think um
but there could be a post-technological
like whatever we think of as technology
that could be uh
a like pre-conscious
like well we all meld into one super
intelligent conscious or some weird
thing that naturally happens over time
yeah i mean i i think that um
we join into a virtual metaverse and and
start creating which is kind of an
interesting idea almost arbitrary
uh number of copies of each other much
more quickly so we can mess with
different ideas like i can create a
thousand copies of lex
uh like every possible version of flex
and then just see like and then i just
have them like argue with each other and
like until like in the space of ideas
and see who wins out
how how could that possibly go wrong but
anyway but that there's uh especially in
this digital space where you could start
exploring with ai's mixed in you can
start engineering arbitrary
intelligences you can start playing in
the space of ideas which might move us
into a world that looks very
different than a biological world like
our current world the technology is
still very much tied to our
biology it's
we we might move past that definitely we
definitely will
definitely that could be another phase
then sure because then you but i did say
technological so i think i agree with
you i think so you can have let's let's
get this right so
um dead world no prospective alive
um prebiotic world life emerging living
and technological and you probably and
the dead one you probably won't be able
to tell between the dead never been
alive and the dead one
maybe what some artifacts so maybe
there's five there's probably not more
than five um and i think the
technological one could allow could have
life on it still but it might just have
exceeded because uh you know one way
that life might survive on earth is if
we can work out how to deal with the
coming
the real climate change that comes when
the sun expands
there might be a way to survive that you
know
um
but um yeah i think that we need to
start thinking statistically when it
comes to
looking for life in the universe let me
ask you then
sort of uh
statistically
how many alien civilizations are out
there
in those four phases that you're talking
about when you look up the stars
and you're sipping on some wine
and um
talking to other people with british
accents about something intelligent
intellectual i'm sure uh
do you think there's uh a lot of alien
civilizations looking back at us
i'm wondering the same my
romantic view of the universe is really
i'm taking loans from my logical self so
what i'm saying is i have no doubt i
have no idea
but
having said that
there is no reason to
suppose that life is as hard as we first
thought it was
and so if we just take earth as a marker
and if i think that life is a much more
general phenomena than just our biology
then i think the the universe is full of
life
and the firm the reason for the fermi
paradox is not that um
they're not out there it's just that we
can't interact with the other life forms
because they're so different
and i'm not saying that they're
necessarily like hasn't depicted in a
rival or other you know um
i'm just saying that perhaps
there are very few universal facts in
the universe
and that and maybe um
that is not it's quite the our
technologies are quite divergent and so
i think that it's very hard to know how
we're going to interact with alien life
you think there's a lot of kinds of life
that's possible i guess that was the
intuition yeah
you provided that uh
the way
biology itself but even this particular
kind of biology that we have on earth
uh is
is something that is just one sample of
on nearly infinite number of other
possible
complex
autonomous self-replicating type of
things that could be possible and so
we're almost
unable to see the alternative
versions of us
huh i mean we'll still be able to detect
them we'll still be able to interact
with them we'll still be able to
like which uh what's exactly is lost in
translation why can't we why can't we
see them why can't we talk to them
because i too
have a sense
you put it way more poetically but
it seems both
statistically
and uh
sort of romantically
it feels like the universe should be
teeming with life like super intelligent
life
and and uh i just i i sit there and the
fermi paradox is very
it's felt very distinctly by me when i
look up at the stars because it's like
it it's uh the same way i feel when i'm
driving through new jersey and listening
to bruce springsteen and i feel quite
sad
uh it's like louis c.k talks about
pulling off to the side of the road and
just weeping a little bit i'm almost
like
wondering like hey why why aren't you
talking to us you know it feels lonely
it feels lonely because it feels like
they're out there
i think that there are a number of
answers to that i think the firming
paradox is is perhaps based on the
the assumption that there's
if life did emerge in the universe it
would be similar to our life
and there's only one solution
um and i think that what we've got to
start to do is go out and look for
selection detection
rather than an evolution detection
rather than life detection
and i and i think that once we start to
do that we might start to see really
interesting things
and we haven't been doing this for very
long um
and we are living in an expanding
universe and that makes the problem a
little bit harder
everybody's always leaving
um but i'm i'm distance wise i'm very
optimistic that we will
well i don't know there are two movies
that came out in the same within six
months of one another
at astra
and cosmos at astra they're very
expensive blockbuster you know with brad
pitt in it and um saying there is no
life and it's all you know we've got a
life on earth as more pressures and
cosmos which is a uk production which
basically aliens came and visited earth
one day and they were discovered in the
uk
right it was quite it's a it's a fun
film
um and but i really loved those two
films and i'm i i and at the same time
those films at the time those films are
coming out i was working on a paper
um a life detection paper and i found it
was so hard to publish this paper
and it was almost as depressing i got so
depressed trying to get this science out
there that i felt
the depression
of the the film and al astra like life
is there's no no life elsewhere in the
universe
and but i but i'm incredibly optimistic
that i think we will find life in the
universe firm evidence of life and it
will have to start on earth making life
on earth and surprising as we have to
surprise ourselves and make
non-biological life on earth and then
people say well you you made this life
on earth therefore it's
you're part of the causal chain of that
and that might be true but if i can show
how i i i'm able to do it with
very little cheating or very little
information inputs just creating like a
a model planet some description and
watching it watching life emerge then i
think that we will be even to to
persuade even the hardest critic
that that is it's possible now with
regards to the fermi paradox
i think that we might crush that with
the jwst
it's basically if i recall correctly the
mirror is about 10 times the size of the
hubble
that we're going to be able to do
spectroscopy look at colors of
exoplanets i think
not brilliantly but we'll be able to
start to classify them
and we'll start to get a real
feel for what's going on in the universe
on these exoplanets because it's only in
the last
few decades i think maybe even last
decade that we even
came to recognize that exoplanets even
are common
and i think that that gives us a lot of
optimism that life is
going to be out there but i think we
have to start framing um
we have to start preparing the fact that
biology is only one solution
i can tell you with confidence that
biology on earth does not exist anywhere
else in the universe we are absolutely
unique
well okay i love the confidence but uh
where does
that confidence come from you know
chemistry
uh
like how many options does chemistry
really have many that's the point and
the thing is this is where the origin of
life scam comes in
uh
is that people
don't quite count they don't count the
numbers so if biology as you find on
earth is common everywhere then there's
something really weird going on that
basically written in the quantum
mechanics there's some kind of these
bonds must form over these bonds and
this catalyst must form over this
catalyst when they're all quite equal
life is contingent the the origin of
life on earth was contingent upon the
chemistry available at the origin of
life
on earth
so that means if we want to find other
life like other earth-like worlds we
look for the same kind of rocky world we
might look in the same zone as as as
earth and we might expect
reasonably to find
biological like stuff going on that
would be a reasonable hypothesis but it
won't be the same it can't be it's like
saying
i don't believe in magic that's why i
i'm sure i just don't believe in magic i
believe in statistics and i can do
experiments and and so i won't get the
same exactly the same sequence of events
i'll get something different
and so there is tick tock elsewhere in
the universe but it's not the same as
our tick tock right
that's that's what i mean which aspect
of it is not the same well i just think
you you it
the so what is tick tock tick tock is a
is a social media where people upload
videos right of silly videos so i guess
there might be there's humor there's
attention there's ability to process
this ability for intelligent organisms
to collaborate on ideas and find human
ideas and play with those ideas make
them viral memes
you know uh
humor seems to be kind of fundamental to
the human experience and i think that um
that's a really interesting question we
can ask is humor
a fundamental thing in the universe i
think maybe it will be right in terms of
if you think about in a game theoretic
sense humor uh the emergence of humor
serves a a role in our game engine and
so
if selection is fundamental in the
universe and so is humor
well i don't actually don't know exactly
what uh
role humor serves maybe it's like uh
from a chemical perspective it's uh like
a catalyst
for uh
i guess it's a several purpose one is
the catalyst for spreading ideas on the
internet that's modern humor but humor
is also a good way to deal
with the difficulty of life
it's a kind of valve
release valve for suffering
like
throughout human history life has been
really hard and for the people that i've
known in my life who've lived through
some
really difficult things uh humorous part
of how they deal with that yeah this is
usually dark humor but
yeah it's interesting i i don't know
exactly sort of the what what's the more
mathematically general way to formulate
what the hell is humor
what humor does it serve but i i still
we're kind of joking here but
it's uh a counterintuitive idea to me
to think that uh
life elsewhere in the universe
is very different than life on earth
and also
like
all of each instantiation of life
is likely very different from each other
yeah like maybe there's a few clusters
of similar like life
but uh it's much more likely is what
you're saying to me it's a kind of novel
thought i'm not sure what to do with it
but you're saying that there's uh
it's more common to be a weird outcast
in the full spectrum of life than it is
to be in some usual cluster so every
instantiation of a kind of
chemistry that results in complexity
that's autonomous and self-replicating
however the hell you define life
that is going to be very different every
time i don't know i
it feels like a selection
is
a fundamental kind of directed force in
the universe won't selection result in a
in a few pockets of interesting
complexities i mean
yeah
if we ran earth over
again over and over and over you're
saying it's going to come up but
there's not going to be elephants every
time
yeah i don't think so i think uh and i
think that there will be similarities
and i think we know we don't know enough
about how selection is um
globally works
um
but it might be might be that the the
elephant
um the emergence of elephants was wired
into the history of earth in some way
like the gravitational force how
evolution was going
cambrian explosions blah blah the
emergence of mammals but i i just don't
know enough about the contingency right
the variability all i do know is you
count the number of bits of information
required to make an element sorry an
elephant and
and
think about the causal chain that
provide the lineage of elephants going
all the way back to luca
there's a huge scope for divergence
yeah but
just like you said with chemistry and
selection
the the things that result in
self-replicating
chemistry
and self-replicating organisms
uh those are extremely unlikely as
you're saying
uh but once they're successful they
multiply so like i i just it might be a
tiny subset of all
of all things that are possible in the
universe chemically speaking it might be
a very tiny subset is actually
successful creating elephants
or uh elephant like
or slash human-like creatures well
there's two different questions here's
the first one if we were to reset earth
and to start again
the different phases sorry to keep
interrupting yeah no if we restart earth
and start again say we could go back
back to the beginning and do the
experiment or have a number of earths um
how similar would biology be i would say
that there would be there would be broad
similarities
but um but the emergence of mammals is
not a given unless we're going to you
know throw an asteroid at each planet
each time and go try and try and
faithfully reproduce what happened
then there's the other the other thing
about
when you go to another earth-like planet
elsewhere maybe there's a different
ratio particular elements maybe there's
uh the bom the bombardment at the
beginning the planet was quicker
or longer than earth and and i just
don't have enough information there what
i do know
is that um
the the complexity of the story of life
on earth
gives us lots of scope for variation and
i just don't think it's a reasonable
mathematical assumption to think that
they will the the life on earth that
happened again would be the same as what
we have now
okay but you've also extended that to
say that we might as an explanation from
the for the fermi paradox that uh that
means we're not able to interact with
them
or that mean that's an explanation for
why we haven't at scale heard from
aliens is um
well right now they're different than us
we've only been looking for say 70 80
years so i think that we're the reason
we have not found aliens yet
is that we haven't worked out what life
is
no but the aliens have worked that out
surely uh i mean
statistically speaking they they must be
there's must be a large number of aliens
that are way ahead of us on this whole
life question
unless there's something about
this stage of uh
intellectual evolution that often
quickly results in nuclear war and
destroys itself like the
there there's something
in this process that eventually i don't
know
crystallizes the complexity and it stops
either dies or stops developing
but most likely they already figured it
out and why aren't they contacting us
there's a some
some grad student somewhere
wants to study a new a new green planet
maybe maybe they have i mean maybe i
mean i don't i mean i don't have a
coherent answer to your question other
than to say that if there are other
aliens out there like and they're
far more advanced they might be in
contact with each other
and they might also um we might be at a
point where what i'm saying quite
critically is it takes two to talk right
yeah so the aliens might be there but if
we if we don't have the ability to
recognize them and talk to them
then the aliens aren't going to want to
talk to us
and i think that's the critical point
and probably
um if if that is a if that's a filter
there needs to be an ability for one to
communicate with the other and we need
to know what life is before we do that
so we haven't qualified to even join
their club to have a talk well i think
they still want to teach us how to talk
right but
my worry is that
or i i think they would want to teach us
how to talk like you do when you meet it
uh
like
when you even meet i was gonna say child
but that's a human species
i mean like and
you want to try to communicate with them
through whatever devices you can given
given what an ant is like i just i worry
mostly about that humans are just too
close minded or don't have the right
tools no i'm going to push back on this
quite significantly i would say because
we don't understand what life is
and because we don't understand how life
immersed in the universe we don't
understand the physics
that gave rise to life yet and
that means our description fundamental
description i'm way out of my pay grade
even further out there better but i'll
say it anyways i think it's you can't
get paid much anyway as you said earlier
so
so
so i would say that we because we don't
understand the universe yet we do not
understand how the universe spat out
life
and we don't know what life is and then
i think that until we understand that it
is going to limit our ability to even
um we don't qualify to talk to the
aliens
so i'm going to say that the the they
might be there but we just i'm not going
to say that i believe in
inter-dimensional aliens being present
yeah but i think you're just being
self-critical uh like we don't qualify i
think i think the fact that we don't
qualify qualifies us we're interesting
we're interested in our innocence no i'm
saying that
because we don't understand
causal chains and the way that
information is propagated in the
universe and we don't understand what
replication is yet and we don't
understand
um how life emerged
i think that we would not recognize
aliens and they and if if someone
doesn't recognize you
um you wouldn't go and talk to it you
don't go and talk to ants
you don't go and talk to birds or maybe
some birds you do right because you can
and there's just enough cognition so i'm
saying because we don't have enough
cognac our cognitive abilities are not
yet where they need to be
we probably haven't been communicating
with them so you don't agree with the uh
dating strategy of playing hard to get
because us humans that's going to
attract us within us within the species
that's fine but i think we don't
actually actually have abstraction no i
i actually i think you've in in this
talk in this conversation you've helped
me crystallize something that i think
has been troubling me for a long time
with the fermi paradox i'm pretty sure
that a a reasonable avenue is to say
that you would not go and talk to
your cat about calculus
right but i would still pet it sure but
i'm not talking about petting a cat the
analogy is that the aliens are not going
to talk to us because we and i'm using
calculus as an analogy for abstraction
because we
we lack the um layer the fundamental
layer for understanding what life is
and what the universe is in our reality
that it's it would be so
counterproductive interacting with
intelligent alien species that it would
cause more angst for the univ for human
race
um they don't care okay they got to be
self-interested so they'll probably they
more care about is it interesting for
them
maybe they
i mean
surely there's a way to to pat the to
pet the cat
in this
this analogy because um
even if we lack complete understanding
it's it must be a very frustrating
experience for
for other kinds of intelligence to
communicate with us still there must be
a way to interact with us well like
perturb the system in interesting ways
to see what these creatures do we might
actually find the answer i mean again at
my pay grade in in in a simulation
of earth or say let's say a simulation
where we allow
an intelligent ai to emerge right and
that and that ai
we then give it
um
the objective is to be curious interact
with other intelligence in its universe
and then we might find
the um the parameters required for that
ai to walk with and i think you'll find
if the the ai will not talk to other ais
that don't share
the ability to abstract the level of the
ai because it's just a cat
and would you are you going to travel 20
light years to go and pet a cat so not
because of the
inability to do so but because of like
boredom it's it's more interested it
will start talking to it will spend most
it will spend a majority of its time
talking to other ai systems that can at
least somewhat understand it's much more
fun it's a bit like do we know that
plants are conscious well plants aren't
conscious in the way we typically think
but we don't talk to them they could be
right but there's a lot of people on
earth who like gardening there's always
going to be a weird thing they're just
gardening okay well you're not romantic
enough to see gardening as a way of
communication between humans oh okay you
got me
but there is there's ways there's always
going to be the people who are curious
jane goodall who lives with the
uh with the chimps right there's always
going to be curious intelligence species
that
visit uh the weird or earth planet and
and try to interact i mean it's it's uh
yeah i i think it's it's a super cool
idea that you're expressing and just to
kind of have a sense maybe it's a hope
that there's always going to be a desire
to interact even with those that don't
can't possibly understand the depth of
what you understand
so i am with you that look so i want to
be as positive as you that we the aliens
do exist and we will we will interact
with them what i'm trying to do is to
give you a
a reasonable hypothesis why we haven't
yet
yeah and also something to strive for to
be able to do that i mean i you know i
there there is the other view that the
the universe is just too big and life is
just too rare
but i want to make come up with an
alternative explanation which i think is
reasonable and not been philosophically
and scientifically thought out which is
this this if you can't actually
communicate with the object
the person the thing
competently you don't even know it's
there yeah then then there's no point
yet see i disagree with that but i'm
totally aligned with your hopeful vision
which is like we need to understand the
origin of life
it will help us engineer life will help
us engineer intelligent life through
perhaps on the computer side of
simulation
and explore all the ways that life
emerges and that will allow us to i
think the fundamental reason we don't
see overwhelming amounts of life
is i actually believe
aliens
of course these are all just kind of um
open-minded beliefs uh it's it's
difficult to know for sure about any of
this but i think there's a lot of alien
civilizations which are actively
communicating with us and we're too dumb
we don't have the right tools that's
what i'm just seeing that's what i'm
saying no but
you're i maybe i misinterpreted you but
you
well i interpreted you to say they kind
of tried a few times and they're like oh
god no no what i'm saying is we so this
goes two ways yeah i agree with you
there could be information out there but
just put in such a way that we just
don't understand it yet right so sorry
if i didn't make that clear i mean it's
not just i don't think we caught i think
we qualify as soon as we can decode
their signal
right so when you say qualified got i
got it so you mean we're just not smart
enough though the word qualifier was
thrown off you know so we're not smart
enough to do it's like yeah but we need
to get smarter yeah
and there's a lot of people who believe
let me get your opinion on this
about ufo sightings
so
sightings of weird phenomena
that uh you know what does ufo mean
it means it's a flying object
and it's not
identified
uh clearly at the time of sighting
that's what ufo means so it could be uh
physics phenomena it could be bald
lightning it could be all kinds of
fascinating i was always fascinated with
ball lightning as a
um
like the fact that there could be
physical phenomena in this world that
are observable by the human eye of
course all physical phenomena generally
are fascinating
that are
that that really smart people can't
explain i love that because it's like
wait a minute especially if you can
replicate it
it's like wait a minute how does this
happen that's like the precursor to
giant discoveries in chemistry biology
and physics and so on but it sucks when
those events are super rare right
physical like like ball lightning
so
so that's out there and then
of course that phenomena could have
other interpretations that don't have to
do with the physics of chemistry the
biology of earth it could have to do
with more
extraterrestrial explanations
that
in large part thanks to hollywood and
movies and all those kinds of things
captivates the imaginations of millions
of people
but just because it's science fiction
that captivates the imagination of
people doesn't mean that some of those
sightings
all it takes is one
one of those sightings
is actually a sign that's it's
extraterrestrial intelligence that it's
um
object that's not of this particular
world do you think there's a chance that
that's the case what do you make
especially the pilot sightings what do
you make of those
um so i i agree there's a chance there's
always a chance any good scientist would
have to
observation this would have to
you know i want to see if aliens exist
come come to earth what i know about the
universe is i think it's unlikely right
now that there are aliens visiting us
but but not impossible
i think the um releases the
dramatization
has been happening politically saying
we're going to release all this
information this you know classified
information
um i was kind of disappointed because it
was just
very poor um
material
and
right now the the you know the the
ability to capture
high-resolution video everybody is
carrying around with an incredible video
device now and
we haven't
got more compelling data and so that
we've just
seeing
grainy pictures
a lot of hear say
instrument kind of malfunctions and
whatnot and so i think on balance i
think it's extremely unlikely but i
think something really interesting is
happening
um
and also during the pandemic right we've
all been locked down we all want to have
we want to our imaginations are you know
running right and i think that the the i
don't think that the the information out
there has convinced me there are any
anything interesting on the ufo side but
what it has made me very interested
about is how humanity is opening up its
mind
to ponder
aliens
and the the mystery of our universe
and so i don't want to dissuade people
from having those thoughts and say
you're stupid and look at that it's
clearly incorrect that's not right
that's not fair what i would say is that
i lack sufficient data replicated
observations to to make me go oh i'm
going to take this seriously
but i'm really interested by the fact
that there is this um
this great deal of interest and i think
that it
drives me
to maybe want to make or make an
artificial life form even more
and to help nasa
and the air force and whoever go and
look for things even more because i
think humanity wants to know what's out
there there's this yearning isn't there
yeah but but i
see i almost
uh depending on the day i sometimes
agree with you but uh
with the thing you just said but
one of the disappointing things to me
about the sightings
i still hold the belief that
a non-zero
number of them
uh
is an indication of something very
interesting
so i don't side with the people who say
everything can be explained with like uh
sensor artifacts kind of thing yeah i'd
agree with you i didn't say that either
i would say i just don't have enough
data right but the thing i want to push
back on is is the statement that
everybody has a high definition camera
one of the disappointing things to me
about like the report that the
government released but in general is
having worked with government having
worked with
with people all over
uh is how incompetent we are
like if you look at the pen response to
the pandemic how incompetent we are
in the face of great challenges
without great leadership
how incompetent we are in the face of
the great mysteries before us without
great leadership and i just think
it's actually the fact that there's a
lot of high definition cameras is not
enough
to capture the full richness of weird
of the mysterious phenomena out there of
which
intelligence visiting earth could be won
i don't think we have i don't think
everybody having a smartphone in their
pocket
is enough
i think that allows for tick-tock videos
i don't think it allows for
the capture of even interesting
relatively rare human events
that's not that common
it's rare to have be in the right moment
in the right time to be able to capture
the thing
i agree i agree let me let me rephrase
what i think on this i i haven't seen
enough information i haven't really
actively sought it out i must admit but
i'm i'm reviewing that i love the idea
of anomaly detection in chemistry in
particular right i want to make
anomalies sorry or not necessarily make
anomalies i want to
understand an anomaly let me give you
two from chemistry
um which are really quite interesting
um phlogiston going way back
where people said there's this thing
called phlogiston and for ages the
alchemist got really um this kind of
this the fire is the thing
um and that's one and we determined that
logistician wasn't what we thought it is
let's go to physics the ether the if is
a hard one because i think actually the
ether might exist and i'll tell you what
i think the ether is later
um
and and and
can you explain either so as the vacuum
so that light traveling through the
ether in the vacuum there is some thing
that we call the ether that that
basically mediates the the movement of
light
say and i think that um and then the
other one is cold fusion which is more
so a few years ago
um that that people observed when they
did some electrochemistry when they were
splitting water into hydrogen and oxygen
that you got more energy out than you
put in and people got excited and they
thought that this was a nuclear reaction
and um and in the end it was kind of
discredited because you didn't detect
neutrons and stuff but
i'm pretty sure
i'm a chemist i'm going telling you this
on your podcast but why not i'm pretty
sure there's interesting electrochemical
phenomena that's not completely bottomed
out yet that there is something there
however we lack the technology and the
experimental design
so all i'm saying in your response about
aliens is that we do we lack the
experimental design to really capture
these anomalies
and we are in circulating encircling the
planet with many more detection systems
we've got satellites everywhere so there
is i do hope that we are going to
discover more anomalies and remember
that
the solar system isn't just static in
space it's moving through the universe
so there's just more and more chance i'm
not what with avi loeb that uh he's
generating all sorts of kind of
um
occult i would say uh with this but
there but i'm not against him i think
there is a finite chance if there are
aliens in the universe that we're going
to happen upon them because we're moving
through the universe what's the nature
of
of the following that uh lobe has it's
doubling down more and more and more and
say there are aliens interdimensional
aliens and everything else right he's
gone from space junk accelerating out of
to interdimensional stuff
in a very short space of time
i see he's obviously bored
or or he wants to tap into the psyche
and understand and you know he's
playfully kind of trying to interact
with society and his peers to say stop
saying it's not possible and which i
agree with we shouldn't do that but we
should frame it statistically in the
same way we should frame any everything
as good scientists
statistically yeah
good scientists recently
the idea of good scientists is um
i take quite skeptically i've been
listening to a lot of scientists telling
me about what is good
what is good science that makes me sad
because you've been interviewing what i
would consider a lot of really good
scientists no that's true
and but that that's exactly right and
most of the people i talk to are
incredible human beings but there's a
humility that's required
science is not um
science cannot be dogmatism sure i agree
i mean authority
like um
a phd does not give you authority
a lifelong pursuit of a particular task
does not give you authority you're just
as lost and clueless as everybody else
but you're more curious
and more stubborn
so that's uh that's a nice quality to
have but overall just
using the word science and
statistics can often
uh as as you know
kind of
become a catalyst for dismissing
new ideas out of the box ideas uh
wild ideas all that kind of stuff well
yes and no i think that so i'm
i like to
some people find me extremely annoying
in science because i'm basically um
i quite rude and disruptive not in a
rude you know so to people say they're
ugly or stupid or anything like that i
just say
you know you're wrong or why do you
think this and and something i a gift i
got given by society when i was very
young because i was in the in the
learning difficulties class at school is
i was told i was stupid
and so i know i know i'm stupid but i
always wanted to be smart right i always
i remember going to school going maybe
today they're going to tell me i i'm not
as stupid as i was yesterday and it was
always disappointed always and so when i
went into academia and everyone says
you're wrong i was like
join the queue yeah
because it allowed me to walk through
the you know the wall so i think that
people like to always imagine science is
a bit like living in a japanese house
their paper walls and everyone sits in
their paper in their room
and i annoy people because i walk
straight through the wall not be because
why should why should i be a chemist and
not a mathematician why should i be a
mathematician not computer scientist
because if the problem requires us to to
walk through those walls
um but
i'm i like walking through the walls
like but i as long then i have to put up
you know i have to do good so i have to
win the people in those rooms
across by good science by
taking their criticisms and addressing
them head on and i think we must do that
and and i think that i i try and do that
in my own way and i i i kind of love
walking through the walls uh and it it
it gives me it's difficult for me
personally it's quite painful um but it
always leads to a deeper understanding
of the people i'm with in particular you
know the arguments i have with all sorts
of interesting minds because
i want to solve the problem or i want to
understand more about why i exist
um you know that's
that's that's it really and i i think we
have to not dismiss science on that
basis i think we can we can work with
science no science is beautiful but uh
humans with egos and all those kinds of
things can
uh sometimes uh misused good things
like social justice like all ideas were
all aspired to misuse these beautiful
ideas
to um
to manipulate people to all those kinds
of things and sure and that's there's
[ __ ] in every
uh space and walk of life including
science yeah yeah and those are those
are no good but yes you're right the the
scientific method
has proven to be quite useful
that said for difficult questions for
difficult
um
rare explanations for rare phenomena
you have to walk cautiously
because
the scientific method when you totally
don't understand something
and it's rare and you can't replicate it
doesn't quite apply
yeah yeah yeah that's it i agree with
you the challenge is to
is to not dismiss the anomaly because
you can't replicate it i mean we can
talk about this this is something i
realized when we were developing
assembly theory um
um that people thinking that the the the
the track they're on is so don't matter
dogmatic where there is this thing
that they see but they don't see and it
takes a bit of time and you just have to
keep reframing it and my approach is to
say well why can't this be right you
know why
why must we accept that rna is the only
way into life i mean who said was there
you know does rna have a special special
uh class of of uh information that's
encoded in the universe no of course it
doesn't right that you know rna is not a
special molecule with in the space of
all the other molecules but it's so
elegant and simple and it works so well
for the evolution process that we kind
of use that as an intuition to explain
that that must be the only way to have
life
sure
uh but you mentioned assembly theory
well first let me pause bathroom break
needed yeah let's take two minutes
we took a quick break and offline you
mentioned to me
that you have a lab in your home
and then i said that you're basically
rick from rick and morty which is
something i've been thinking this whole
conversation
and then you say
that there's a glowing pickle
that you used something involving cold
plasma i believe i don't know but can
you explain the and pickle situation
[Laughter]
and is there many arbitrarily many
versions of you in alternate dimensions
so i think you're aware of i tried to
make an
electrochemical memory in at home
um using a and the only way using a
pickle the only way i could get any um
traction with it was actually by
plugging it into a very high voltage
alternating current and then putting in
a couple electrodes but my kids weren't
impressed they're not impressed with
anything i do any experiments i do at
home i think it's quite funny but you
connected to a pickle to some electro i
mean 240 volts yeah ac yeah and then had
a couple of electrodes on it so what
happens is a pickle um
this is a classic thing you do
i mean i shouldn't pranks you do you put
a pluck pickle into the mains and just
leave it run away and leave it and what
happens is it it starts to decompose it
heats up and then explodes because the
water turns to steam and it just
violently explodes but i wondered if i
could cause the iron sodium potassium
ions in the pickle to migrate it'd been
in a jar right it's been in a in a brine
that was yeah that was not my that was
not my best experiment so i've done far
better experiments in my lab at home at
that time was a failed experiment but
you never know it could uh
every experiment is a successful
experiment uh if you stick with it long
enough well i mean i get i got kicked
out of my own lab by my research team
many years ago and for good reason i
mean my team is brilliant and i used to
go and just break things
so what i do do at home is i have a kind
of electronics workshop
um and i prototype experiments there
then i try and then i try and suggest to
my team sometimes maybe we can try this
thing
and they would just say oh well that's
not going to work because of this and
i'll say aha but actually i've tried and
here's some code and here's some
hardware can we have a go so that i'm
doing that less and less now as i get
even more busy but um that's quite fun
because then they feel that we're in the
you know in the experiment together you
do in fact
brilliantly
just like rick from rick and morty uh
connect up chemistry
with computation
so
sort of
and when we say chemistry we don't mean
the
simulation
of chemistry
a modeling of chemistry we mean
chemistry in the physical space as well
as in the digital space which is
fascinating we'll
talk about that but first you mentioned
assembly theory so we'll stick on
theory and these big ideas
i would say revolutionary ideas
this uh intersection between
mathematics and philosophy what is
assembly theory
and generally speaking how would we
recognize life
if we saw it
so assembly theory is a theory
goes back a few years now my struggle
for maybe almost 10 years
when i was going to origin of life
conferences and artificial life
conferences where i thought that
everybody was dancing around
the problem of what life is and what it
does
but i'll tell you about what assembly
theory is because i think it's easier so
assembly theory literally says if you
take an object
any given object
and you are able to break that object
into parts very gently so just maybe
let's say take a piece of very intricate
chinese porcelain and you tap it just on
the hammer or the nail at some point and
it will fragment into many parts
and if that object is able to fragment
into many and you count those num those
parts the different parts so they're
unsymmetrical
um assembly theory says
the
larger the number of parts unsymmetrical
parts that object has the more likely it
is that object has been created by an
evolutionary or information process
especially
if that object is not one-off you've got
a an abundance of them
and that's really important the abundant
i and i so because if you what i'm
literally saying about the abundance if
you have a one-off object and you break
it into parts
and it has lots of lots of parts you'd
say well that's
that could be
incredibly intricate and complex but it
could be just random
and i was troubled with this for years
because i saw in reality that assembly
theory worked but when i talked to very
good computational
complexity computationalists algorithmic
complexity people they said you haven't
really done this properly you haven't
thought about it it's like this this is
the random problem
and so um i kept working this up because
i invented an assembly theory
in chemistry first of all with molecules
and so the thought experiment was
how complex does a molecule need to be
when i find it that it couldn't possibly
have risen by chance probabilistically
and if i found this molecule able to
detect it enough quantities in the same
object like a machine like a mass
spectrometer so typically in a mass
spectrometer you weigh the molecules in
electric field you probably have to have
on the order of 10 000 identical
molecules to get a signal so 10 000
identical molecules that are complex
what's the chance of them occurring by
chance
well we can do the math let's take a
molecule like strychnine or
um
or yes a stricken is a good molecule
actually to take
or viagra is a good molecule i have made
jokes about viagra because it's complex
molecule and one of my friends said yeah
if we find viagra on mars in detectable
quantities we know something is up
yeah but anyway it's a complex molecule
so what you do is you take this molecule
in the mass spectrometer and you hit it
with some electrons or an electric field
it breaks apart
and if the larger than the larger the
number of different parts you know
when it starts to get to a threshold my
idea was that that molecule could not be
created by chance probabilistically
so that was where assembly thought
theory was born in an experiment in a
mass spec experiment and i was thinking
about this because nasa's sending the
mass spectrometers to mars to titan
is going to send them to europa there's
going to be a nuclear-powered mass
spectrometer going to titan
this i mean this is the coolest
experiment ever they're not only sending
a drone that's going to fly around titan
it's going to be
powered by a you know
a nuclear slug a nuclear battery and
it's going to have a mass spectrometer
on it is this already launched no it's
going to it's dragonfly and it's going
to be launched in a few years i think it
got pushed a year because of the
pandemic
so i think you you three or four years
fly
nuclear dragonfly is going to fly to
titan
uh and collect
uh
data about the composition
of the various chemicals on titan yeah
i'm trying to convince nasa i don't know
if i'll be able to convince the dragon
fly team
um that they should apply this approach
but they will get data and depending on
how good their mass spectrometer is but
i had this thought experiment anyway i
did this thought experiment
and for me it seemed to work i i turned
the thought experiment into an algorithm
in assembly theory and i basically
assembly theory if i take let's just
make it generic and let's just take the
word abracadabra say can i
um if you find the word so if you have a
book with lots of words in it and you
find abracadabra one off and it's a wrap
book that's been written by
in a random way you know set of monkeys
in a room and you know head type and
you're on typewriters and you find one
or fabric adapter no big deal but if you
find lots of reoccurrences of
abracadabra well that means something
weird is going on but let's think about
the assembly number of abracadabra
so
abracadabra has a you know
has a number of letters in it you can
break it down so you just cut the
letters up
but when you actually reassemble
abracadabra the minimum number of ways
of organizing those letters so you'd
have an a a b
you know
uh and keep going up
um there's just that you can when you
cut abracadabra up into parts you can
put it together again in seven steps so
what does that mean that means if you
basically don't re you're allowed to
reuse things you make in the chain at
the beginning
that's the memory of the universe the
process that makes abracadabra
and because that causal chain you can
then get to abracadabra quicker than the
number of letters if we're having to
specify only in seven
so if you take that to a molecule and
you cut the molecule up
into parts
and you can on the causal chain and you
basically start with the atoms and then
bonds and then you randomly add on those
parts to make the a make the b
make the and keep going all the way up
um i found that literally assembly
theory allows me to say how compressed a
molecule is
so when there's some information in
there
um and i realized that assembly theory
is it wasn't isn't just
confined to molecular space it can apply
to anything but let me finish the
molecular argument so what i did is i
i had this theory i was one of my one of
my students we wrote an algorithm
we basically took the
20 million molecules from the database
and we just calculated their assembly
number
and that's the index like basically
if i take a molecule and i cut it up
into bonds
what is the minimum number of steps i
need to take to reform that molecule
from atoms so reusability of previously
foreign things is somehow fundamental
exactly it's like a memory in the
universe right i'm making lots of leaps
here like it's kind of weird i'm saying
right there's a process that can form
the a and the b and the c let's say and
then when there's and because we've
formed a and b before we can use a and b
again with no extra cost except one unit
so that's the kind of what the chain of
events and that's how you think about
memory here when you say the universe
when you talk about the universe and or
life is the universe
creating memory exactly so we we we went
through chemical space and we looked at
the assembly numbers and we were able to
classify it we said okay
let's test it let's go so we're able to
take a whole bunch of molecules and
assign an assembly index to them
okay and it's just those
as a function of the number of bonds in
the molecule how much symmetry so
literally assembly theory is a measure
of how little symmetry a molecule has so
the more asymmetry the more information
the more weird it is like a jackson
pollock or some description so i then
went
and did a load of experiments and i
basically took those molecules i cut
them up in the mass spec and measured
the number of peaks without any
knowledge of the molecule
and we found the assembly num then the
there was a almost
not quite a one-to-one correlation but
almost because not all bonds are equal
they have different energies i then did
this using two other spectroscopic
techniques nmr nuclear magnetic
resonance which uses radio frequency to
to basically jangle the molecules and
get a signature out and i also used
infrared
and infrared and nmr almost gave us a
one-to-one correlation so what am i
saying
saying by
taking a molecule and do it and and
doing either infrared or nmr or mass
spec
i can work out
how many parts there are in that
molecule and then put it on a scale
and what we did
in the next part of the work
is um we took molecules randomly from
the environment from outer space from
all around earth from the the the from
the sea from antarctica
and from fossils and so on and even nasa
and they because they didn't believe us
blinded some samples
and that we found that all
these samples that
came from biology
produced molecules that had a very high
assembly number above a threshold of
about 15.
so basically
all the other stuff that came from our
ebiotic origin
was low there was no complexity there so
we suddenly realized that on earth at
least there is a cut-off that
natural phenomena
cannot produce molecules that need more
than 15 steps to make them
so i realized that this is a way to make
a scale of life a scale of technology as
well
and
literally you could just go sniffing for
molecules off earth on titan on mars and
when you find a molecule in the mass
spectrometer that gives you more than 15
parts you'll know
pretty much for sure
that it had to be produced by evolution
and this allowed me to come up with a
general definition of life based on
assembly theory to say that if i find an
object
that has a that has a large number of
parts say an iphone or boeing 747 or you
know
any complex object and i can find it in
abundance and cut it up
i can tell you whether that has been
produced by an informational process or
not and that's what assembly theory kind
of does
but it goes a bit further
i then realized that this isn't just
about life it's about causation
so actually it tells you about where
there's a causal structure so now i can
look at objects in the universe say that
again this cup and say right i'm going
to look at how many independent parts it
has
so that's the assembly number
i'll then look at the abundance how many
cups are two on this table maybe there's
a few more you got stashed away so
assembly is a is a function of
the complexity of the object
times the number of copy numbers of that
object or a function of the copy number
normalized so i realize there's a new
quantity in the universe you have energy
entropy and assembly
so assembly the way we should think
about that is uh how much uh reusability
there is
because
reusability is like the like can you
play devil's advocate to this so like
could this just be
a nice
uh
tertiary signal
for living organisms
like some kind of distant signal that's
yeah this is a nice property but it's
not capturing something fundamental or
do you think reusability is something
fundamental to the life and complex
organisms i think reusability is
fundamental in the universe
not just for life and complex or
organisms it's about causation
so i think assembly
tells you if you find objects because
you can do this reject trajectories as
well you think about it that
in the unit the fact there are objects
in the universe on earth his mind is
weird
you think about it we should just have a
commentary explosion of stuff
the fact that not everything exists
is
is really weird
now and then
as i'm looking at two mugs and two water
bottles and uh the things that exist
kind of
uh
are similar and multiply
yeah in copies yeah yeah so i would say
that assembly allows you to do something
that statistical mechanics
and people looking at entropy have got
stuck with yeah for a while
so i'm making it's pretty bold i mean
i'm writing a paper with sarah walker on
this at the moment and we're realizing
we don't want to get ahead of ourselves
because i think that there's lots of
ways where this
is you know it's it's a really
interesting idea it works for molecules
and it appears to work for any objects
produced by causation because you can
take a motor car you can look at the
assembly of the motor car look at a book
look at the assembly of the book
assembly theory tells you there's a way
of
compressing and reusing and so when
people i talk to
information theorists they say oh this
is just logical depth i say it is like
logical depth but it's experimentally
measurable
they say oh it's a bit like common
golovk complexity and so but it's
computable
and now okay it's not infinitely
computable gets mp hard very quickly
right it's very hard problem when you
could get but it's uncomputable enough
you're contractible enough to be able to
tell the difference between a molecule
that's been formed by the random
background and by
uh causation
and and i think that that's really
interesting because
until now there's no way of measuring
complexity objectively
complexity has required
algorithmic comparisons and programs
and human beings to label things
assembly is label-free
well not entirely we can talk about what
that means in a minute
okay um my my brain has been uh
broken a couple of times sorry i
explained it really badly no it was very
well explained it was just fascinating
and uh
it's uh
it's a my brain is broken into pieces
and i'm trying to assemble it
uh so np hard
so when you have a molecule
you're trying to figure out okay
if we were to reuse parts of this
molecule which parts can we
reuse
to
uh as an optimization problem and be
hard
to figure out the minimum amount of
reused components
that will create this molecule and it
becomes difficult when you start to look
at a huge huge molecules arbitrarily
large because i'm also like mapping this
can i can i think about this
in complexity generally like looking at
a cellular automata system and saying
like what's the what can this be used as
a measure of complexity for like uh
arbitrarily complicated system
yeah i think it can it can and i think
that the question is then what's the
benefit because there's plenty of
um
i mean in computer science and
mathematics and physics people have been
really seriously studying complexity for
a long time
and i think there's some really
interesting problems of where we course
grain
and we lose information and all assembly
theory does really assembly theory just
explains weak emergence
and and so what assembly theory says
look
going from the atoms into atoms that
interact those first replicators that
build one another
um assembly at the the minimal level
just tells you evidence that there's
been replication and selection
and i think the more selected something
is the higher the assembly
and so we we're able to start to know
how to look for selection in the
universe if you go to the moon there's
nothing a very high assembly on the moon
except the human artifacts we've left
there
so again let's go back to the sandbox
in assembly theory says if all the sand
grains could stick together that's the
infinite conventory explosion in the
universe that should be the default
well we don't have that now let's
assemble sand grains together and what
that's um and do them in every possible
way so we have a series of minimal
operations that can move the sound
together but all that doesn't exist
either now because we have specific
memory where we say what we're going to
put three sand grains in a line or four
and make a cross or a triangle or
something unsymmetrical and once we've
made the triangle the unsymmetrical
thing we remember that we can use it
again because on that causal chain
so what assembly theory allows you to do
is go to the actual object that you
exist you find in space and actually the
way you get there is by disassembling it
so
this assembly theory works by
disassembling objects you have and
understanding the the steps to create
them and it works with map for bot for
molecules beautifully because you just
break bonds
but like you said it's not be hard it's
very difficult
it's a difficult problem to figure out
how to break them apart for molecules
it's easy if you just keep low enough in
molecular weight space
it's good enough so it's a complete
theory
when we start to think about objects we
can start to assign we can start to
think about things at different levels
different atoms what do you assign as
your atom
so in a molecule the atom this is really
confusing because the word atom i mean
smallest breakable part so in a molecule
the atom is the bond because you break
bonds not atoms right right
so in a car the atom might be i don't
know a small amount of iron or the
smallest you know reusable part a rivet
uh a piece of plastic or something so
you've got to be really careful in a
microprocessor the atoms might be
transistors
and so
how are some the amount of assembly that
something as is a function you have to
look at the the atom level what are you
where are your parts what are you
counting that's one of the things you
get to choose
what is uh what scale is they add what
is the minimum exact thing i mean
there's a huge amount of trade-offs in
when you approach a system and try to
analyze like if you approach earth
you're an alien civilization try to
study earth what is the atom for trying
to measure the complexity of of life
is it uh are humans the atoms i would
say to start with you just use molecules
i can say for sure if there are
molecules of sufficient complexity on
earth then i know that life has made
them and then go further and show
technology there are molecules that
exist
on earth that are not possible even by
biology you needed technology and you
needed microprocessors to get there
so that's really cool and that there's a
correlation between
that uh between the the coolness of that
and uh assembly number whatever the
measure what's the what would you call
the measure assembly index yeah so yes
there are three kind of fundamental kind
of labels we haven't so there's the
quantity of assembly and the assembly
so if you have a box let's just have a
box of molecules so i'm gonna have my
box
we count the number of identical
molecules and then we chop each molecule
up in a individual molecule class and
calculate the assembly number so
basically that you then have a function
that sums over
all the molecules for each assembly and
then you divide through so you make it
uh divided by the number of of molecules
so that's the assembly index for the box
so that will tell you some amount of
assembly in the box so basically the
assembly equation we come up with is
like basically the sum
of e to the power of the assembly index
for molecule i times the number of
copies of the molecule i
and then you normalize so you sum them
all up and then normalize so some boxes
are going to be more assembled than
others
yeah that's what they tell me so if you
were to look at me as a box the same a
box
uh am i some of my parts in terms of
like how do you know what what's my
assembly index so i'm going to be gentle
so let's just we'll talk about the
molecules and use so let's just take a
pile of sand the same way as you mm-hmm
and
and i would
um take you and just cut up all the
molecules
i mean and and look at the number of
copies an assembly number so in sand
let's say there's probably going to be
nothing more than a semi number of two
or three
but there might be trillions and
trillions of sand grains and your body
there might be the assembly numbers
going to be higher but there might not
be quite as many copies because the the
molecular weight is higher
so you do want to average it out you
kind of you can do averages i'm not i'm
not defined by the most impressive model
no no you're an average in your volley
what i mean we're just working this out
but what's really cool
is they're you're going to have a really
high assembly the sand will have a very
low assembly your causal power
is much higher you get to make decisions
you're alive you're aspiring assembly
says something about causal power in the
universe and that's not supposed to
exist
because physicists don't accept that
causation exists at the bottom so i
understand at the chemical level why the
assemblies cause
causation why is it causation because
it's capturing the memory
exactly capturing memory but there's not
an action to it
so um
i'm trying to see
how it leads to
life well it's what life does
so i think it's we we don't know
so yeah that's a good question what is
life versus what does life do yeah so
that's this is the definition of life
the only definition we need right the
assembly is that life
is able to create objects in abundance
that are that are
so complex this semi number is so high
they can't possibly form by in around in
an environment where there's just random
interactions yeah so the so suddenly you
can put life on a scale um and then life
doesn't exist actually
in that can it's just how evolved you
are
and
you as an object because you have
incredible causal power you could go and
you can go and you know
um
launch rockets or build cars or
create drugs or you know it's you can do
so many things you can build stuff build
more artifacts that show that you have
had causal power and that causal power
was there's kind of a lineage and i
think that over time
i've been realizing that the physics
as a discipline
has a number of problems associated with
me as a chemist is kind of interesting
that assembly theory and i'm really
you know i want to maintain some some
credibility in the physicist size but i
have to push them because they're
physics
is a really good discipline it's it's
reduced the number physics is about
reducing the belief system but they're
down to some things in their belief
system yeah which is kind of really
makes me kind of grumpy number one is
requiring order at the beginning
universe magically we don't need that
the second is the second law well we
don't actually need that
and i this is blasphemous
in a minute i i'll recover my career in
a second although i think the good the
only good thing about being the regis
chair means i think there has to be an
act of parliament to fire me
[Laughter]
so you know you can always go to lee's
twitter and protest
and i think the third thing is that so
we've got you know we've got the um the
order at the beginning yeah um second
law yeah the second law and the fact
that causation is emergent
right and that time is immersion
carol just turned off this program
i think he believes that it's immersion
so causation is not that's clearly
incorrect
because we wouldn't exist otherwise so
tight so physicists have kind of got
confused about time
time is a real thing well i mean so look
i'm very happy with the current
description of the universe as physics
give me because i do a lot of stuff
right i can go to the moon with
newtonian physics i think and i can
understand um the the orbit of mercury
with relativity
and so and i can build transistors with
quantum mechanics right and i can do all
this stuff yeah so i'm not saying the
physics is wrong i'm just saying
if we say that time is fundamental i.e
time is non-negotiable there's a global
clock
i don't neither i don't need to require
that there's order been magically made
in the past because that asymmetry is
built into the way the universe is
so if time's fundamental i mean
you've been referring to this kind of
an interesting formulation that is
memory
yeah
so uh time time is hard to like put a
finger on like what what the hell are we
talking about well it's just a direction
but memory
is a construction especially when you
have like
think about these local pockets of
complexity these um
non-zero assembly index entities that's
being constructed and they remember
never forget molecules but remember the
thing is i invented assembly theory
um i'll tell you i invented it when i
was a kid i mean i the thing is i keep
making fun of myself from a research
group i've only ever had one idea i keep
exploring that idea over the 40 years or
so since i had that idea
well aren't you the idea that the
universe had so it's very kind of
hierarchical anyway go ahead i'm sorry
that's that's very oh that's very poetic
yeah
so i think i came up with assembly
theory the following idea when i was a
kid i was obsessed about survival kits
what is the minimum stuff i would need
to basically replicate my reality and i
love computers
and i love technology or what
technologies can become so i imagined
that i would have basically this really
big truck full of stuff and i thought
well can i delete some of that stuff out
can i have a blueprint and then and in
the end i kept making this making it
smaller i got to maybe half a truck and
into a suitcase and then went okay i'll
screw it i want to i want to carry my
entire technology in my pocket how do i
do it and i'm not like a launch interest
steve jobian you know i'm iplayer
i came up with a matchbox survival kit
in that matchbox survival kit i would
have the minimum stuff that would allow
me to interact the environment to build
my shelter to build a fishing rod to
build a water purification system and
it's kind of like so what did i use in
my box to assemble
in the environment to assemble to
assemble to assemble
and and i realized i could make a causal
chain in my survival kit so i guess
that's probably why i've been obsessed
with assembly theory for so long and i
was just
pre-configured to find it somewhere
and when i saw it in molecules i i
realized that the causal structure that
we say emerges
and the physics kind of gets really
stuck because they're saying that time
you can go backwards in time i mean how
do we let physicists get away with the
notion that we can go back in time and
meet ourselves i mean that
that's clearly
a very
hard thing
to let we physicists would not let
other scientists get away with
that kind of heresy right so why
physicists allowed to get away with it
let's so first of all to push back
to play devil's advocate you are clearly
married to the idea of memory
you see in this
again rick from rick and morty way you
see you you have these deep dreams of
the universe that is writing the story
through its memories those these
chemical compounds that are just
building on top of each other and and
then they they find useful components
they can reuse and then they're they're
reused components
uh create systems that themselves are
then reused and all in this way
construct things
but
when you think of that as memory
it seems like quite sad that you can
walk that back but at the same time it
feels like that memory you can walk in
both directions on that memory in in
terms of time you could walk in both
directions but i don't i don't think
that that makes any sense because
um the problem that i have with time
being
reversible
is that um
i mean i'm i'm just a you know i'm a
dumb experimental chemist right so i
love burning stuff you know burning
stuff and building stuff
but when i think of reversible phenomena
i imagine in my head i have to actually
manufacture some time i have to i have
to borrow time from the universe to do
that i can't when anyone says let's
imagine that we can go back in time or
reversibility you can't do that you
can't step out of time time is
non-negotiable it's happening no but see
you're assuming that time is fundamental
which most of us do when we go
day-to-day but it takes a leap of wild
imagination to think that time is
emergent um no time is not emergent yeah
i mean this is an argument we can have
but i believe
i can come up with an experiment an
experiment that proves that time cannot
possibly be emerging experiment that
shows how
assembly theory
kind of
is the way that the universe produces
selection and that selection gives rise
to life
and also to say well hang on
we could allow ourselves to have a
theory that requires us to have these
these statements to be possible
like we need we need to have
order in the past or we can have use the
past hypothesis
um which is order in the past but
as well
okay
and we have to have an arrow of time we
have to require that entropy
it increases and we have to say and then
we can say look the universe is
completely closed and there's no novelty
or that novelty is predetermined what
i'm saying is very very important that
time is fundamental which means if you
think about it the universe becomes more
and more novel each step it generates as
more states and next step than it was
before that means bigger search
so what i'm saying is that the universe
wasn't capable of consciousness at day
one
actually because it didn't have enough
states
but but today the universe is complex so
it's like all right all right hold on a
second
now we've pissed off the pant cycles too
okay
no just brilliant sorry i'm
a part of me is just you know joking
having fun with this thing but uh
because you're saying a lot of brilliant
stuff and i'm trying to slow it down
before my brain explodes so because i
want to break break apart some of the
fascinating things you're saying so
novelty
novelty is increasing in the universe
because the number of states is
increasing what do you mean by states so
i think the physicists almost got
everything right i can't i can't fault
them at all
i just think there's a little bit of dog
i'm just trying to play devil's advocate
i'm very happy to be entirely wrong on
this right you know i'm not right on
many things at all
but
but if i can make less assumptions about
the universe with this then potentially
that's a more powerful way of looking at
things
if you think if time is fundamental yeah
you can make less assumptions overall
exactly
the time sunder meant i don't need to
add on a magical second law because the
second law comes out the fact the
universe is actually there's more states
available i mean we might even be able
to do weird things like dark energy in
the universe might actually just be time
right yeah but then you have to still
have to explain why time's fundamental
because i can give you one explanation
that's simply a time to say god
you know like just because it's simple
doesn't mean it's
but okay you still have to explain god
and you still have to explain time like
why is it fundamental so let's just say
existence is default which means time is
the default so
how did you go from the existence this
is the thing
well look we exist right so let's just
we'll just just take be very we're yet
to talk about what exists means all
right let's listen all the way back yeah
yeah okay i think it's very poetic and
beautiful what you're weaving into this
i i don't think this conversation is
even about the assembly
uh which is fascinating and we'll keep
mentioning it assembly index and this
idea
that i don't think is necessarily
connected to time oh i think it is
deeply connected like i can't explain it
yet so you don't think everything you've
said about assembly theory and assembly
index
can still be correct even if time is
emergent so yeah right now assembly
theory appears to work i appear to be
able to measure objects of high assembly
in a mass spectrometer and look at their
abundance and you know all that's fine
right it's a it's a nice if nothing else
it's a nice way of looking at how
molecules can compress things
um
now am i saying that a time has to be
fundamental not immersion for assembly
theory to work no i'm i think i'm saying
that the universe
it appears that the universe has many
different ways of using time you could
have three different types of time you
could just have time that's
the way i'd think of it if you want if
you want to hold on to emergent time i
think that's fine let's do that for a
second hold on to emergent time
and the universe is just doing its thing
then assembly time only exists when the
universe starts to write memories
through bonds so let's just say there's
rocks running around you know there's
when when the bond happens and selection
starts suddenly
there are there the universe is
remembering causing in the past and
those structures will have effects in
the future so suddenly a new type of
time emerges at that point which has a
direction and i think sean carroll at
this point might even turn the podcast
back on and go okay i can deal with that
that's fine but i'm just basically
trying to condense the conversation and
say hey let's just have time fundamental
and see how that screws with people's
minds why you're triggering people by
saying fundamental why not we just say
like let's say why am i look i'm walking
through the wall why why
why should i
grow up in a world where time ty i don't
go back in time i don't mean i don't
meet myself in the past there are no one
there are no aliens coming from the
future right
you know it's just like oh no no but
that's not no no no no that's like
saying
we're talking about biology or like uh
evolutionary psychology and you're
saying okay let's just assume that that
clothing is fundamental people wearing
clothes is fundamental it's like no no
wait a minute
you can't like i think you're getting in
a lot of trouble as you assume time is
fundamental why give me one reason why
i'm getting into trouble time being
fundamental because you might not
understand the origins of this memory
that might be deeper like that this
memory that could be a thing
that's explaining the construction of
these
uh higher complexities better
than just saying
it's a it's a search it's it's chemicals
doing a search
for
uh
reusable
uh reusable structures that they can
like
then use as bricks to build the house
okay so i accept that so let's let's
let's go back a second because it's a
kind of it is i wanted to drop the time
bomb at this part because i think we can
carry on discussing it for many many
many many many days many months um but
i'm happy
to accept that it might be wrong but
what i would like to do is imagine a
universe where time is fundamental and
time is emergent
and ask
let's just then talk about causation
because physicists require that
causation so this is where i'm going to
go causation emerges
and it doesn't exist at the micro scale
that clearly is wrong because if
causation has to emerge at the macro
scale life cannot emerge so how does
life emerge life requires molecules to
bump into each other produce replicators
those replicators need to produce
polymers there needs to be cause and
effect at the molecular level there
needs to be in a girded non-aegonic to a
negative transition right at some point
and
and
those replicators
have consequence material consequence in
the universe
physicists just say oh you know what i'm
gonna have a bunch of particles in the
box i'm going to i'm going to think
about it in a newtonian way in a quantum
way and i'll add on an arrow time
so i can label things
and causation will happen magically
later well how explain causation
and they can't the only way i can
reconcile causation
is having a fundamental time
because this allows me to have a
deterministic universe that is creates
novelty
and we and there's so many there's so
many things to unpack here but let's go
back to the point you said does can
assembly theory work with emergent time
sure it can but it doesn't give me a
deep satisfaction about how causation
ca and assembly gives rise to these
objects that that move through time and
space
and again what am i saying to bring it
back
i can say
without fear you know take this water
bottle and look at this water bottle and
look at the features on it there's
writing you've got a load of them um i
know that
causal structures gave rise to this in
fact i'm not looking at just one water
bottle here i'm looking at every water
bowl has ever been conceived of by
humanity
this here is a special
object in fact leibniz knew this you
know leibniz um it was at the same time
of newton he kind of got stuck i think
leibniz actually invented assembly
theory he gave soul the soul that you
see in objects wasn't the mystical soul
it is assembly it is a fact there's been
a history of objects related and without
without the object in the past this
object wouldn't exist there is a lineage
and there is conserved structures causal
structures have given rise to those
fair enough and uh you're saying it's
just a simpler view if time
is fundamental and it and it shakes the
physicist's cage a bit right because i'm
gonna say but i think that
i i just i just enjoy the fact that
physicists are in cages i think that i
mean i would say that you know
lee smolin i don't want to speak for lee
i'm talking to lee about this i think
lee also is in agreement that time is
has to be fundamental but i think he
goes further you know
even in space i don't think you can go
back to the same place in space
i've been to austin a few times now this
is my
i think third time i've been to austin
is austin in the same place no
the solar system is moving through space
i'm not back in the same space locally i
am
every event in the universe is unique
in space and time and time doesn't mean
we can't go back though i i mean uh you
know i mean let's just
you know rest this conversation which
was
beautiful
uh with a quote from the rolling stones
that uh you can't always get what you
want which is you want time to be
fundamental
but if you try you'll get what you need
which is assembly theory
okay let me ask you about continue
talking about complexity
and uh
to clarify with this
beautiful theory of yours that you're
developing and i'm sure we'll continue
developing both in the lab and in theory
um
yeah it's
can't be said enough
just the ideas you're playing with in
your head are just
and we've been talking about are just
beautiful so if we talk about complexity
a little bit more generally
maybe in an admiring romantic way how
does complexity emerge from simple rules
the why the how
okay the nice algorithm of assembly is
there
i would say that the problem i have
right now is i mean you're right we can
about time as well
the problem is i have this hammer called
assembly
and everything i see is a nail
so now
let's just apply it to all sorts of
things we take the bernard instability
the bernard instability is you have oil
uh if you heat up oil
let's say on a frying pan when you get
convection you get honeycomb patterns
take the formation of snowflakes
right um take the take the emergence of
a
of a tropical storm or the storm on
jupiter
when people say let's talk about
complexity in general what they're
saying is
let's take this collection of objects
that are correlated in some way
and try and work out how many moving
parts or how this got
how this exists so what people have been
doing for a very long time is taking
complexity and counting what they've
lost
calculating the entropy
and the reason why i'm pushing very hard
on assembly is entropy tells you how
much you've lost
it doesn't tell you the microstates are
gone
but if you embrace the go the bottom up
with assembly those states and you you
you then understand the causal chain
that gives rise to the emergence so what
i think
assembly will help us do is understand
weak emergence at very least
and maybe allow us to
crack open complexity in a new way
and and i've been fascinated with
complexity theory
for many years i mean whenever
as soon as i could you know i learned of
the mandelbrot set and i could write
write is just type it up in my computer
and run it and just show it and see it
kind of unfold
it was just
this
this kind of this mathematical reality
that existed in front of me i just found
incredible but then i realized that
actually we were cheating
we're putting in the boundary conditions
all the time we're putting in
information
and so
when people talk to me about the
complexity of things i say but relative
what how do you measure them so my
attempt my small attempt um
naive attempt
because there's many greater minds than
mine on the planet right now thinking
about this properly and you've had some
of them on the podcast right they're
just absolutely fantastic
but i'm wondering if we might be able to
reformat the way we would explore com
com algorithmic complexity
using assembly let's what's the minimum
number of
constraints we need
in our system for this to unfold
so whether it's like you know
if you take some particles and put them
in a box
at a certain box size you get
quasi-crystallinity coming out right
but that quite that emergence
it's not magic
it must come from the boundary
conditions you put in
so all i'm saying is a lot of the
complexity that we see
is a direct read of the constraints we
put in but we just don't understand so
as i said earlier to the poor origin of
life chemists you know
origin of life is a scam i would say
lots of complexity calculation theories
a bit of a scam because we put the
constraints in but we don't count them
correctly
and i'm wondering if oh
you're thinking and starting to drop as
an assembly theory uh something index is
a way to counter the constraints yes
that's it it's all it is so assembly
theory doesn't do doesn't lower any of
the importance of complexity theory but
it allows us to go across domains and
start to compare things compare the
complexity of a molecule of a
microprocessor of the texture of writing
of this of the music you may compose
you've tweeted quote assembly theory
explains why nietzsche understood with
limited freedom rather than radical
freedom
so we've applied assembly theory to
cellular automata in life and chemistry
um what does nietzsche have to do with
uh somebody oh that gets me into free
will and everything
so let me say that again assembly theory
explains why nietzsche understood we had
limited freedom
rather than radical freedom limited
freedom freedom i suppose is referring
to the fact that there's constraints
or um
what is radical freedom what is freedom
so sartre was like believed in absolute
freedom
um and that he could do whatever he
wanted in his imagination
and nietzsche understood that his
freedom was somewhat more limited
and it kind of takes me back to this
computer game that i played when i was
10. so i think it's called dragon's lair
okay do you know dragon slayer i think i
know dragons there yeah dragon slayer i
knew i was being conned right dragon's
lair when you play the game you're lucky
that you grew up in a basically
procedurally generated worlds that was
rpg a little bit no it's like uh is it
turn-based play was it it was a it was a
role-playing game but really good
graphics and won the first laserdiscs
and when you actually flicked the stick
you you took it's like it was like a
graphical adventure game with animation
yeah and when i played this game i
really you know you could get through
the game in 12 minutes if you knew what
you were doing for not making mistakes
just play the display display disc so it
was just about timing and actually was a
complete fraud because all the animation
has been pre-recorded on the disk yeah
it's like the black mirror the first
interactive where they had all the you
know several million uh kind of uh
permutations of the movie that you could
select on netflix i've forgotten the
name of it
so this was a exactly that in the
laserdisc so you basically go left go
right
fight the ogre
slay the dragon and when you flick the
joystick at the right time it just goes
to the next animation to play yeah it's
not really generating it yeah and i
played that game and i knew i was being
had
so to you
uh dragon lair is the first time you
realize that free will is an illusion
yeah
and
why why not does assembly theory give
you hints about free will whether it's
an illusion or not yeah so no so not
tightly if i do think i have some will
and i think i am an agent and i think i
can interact and i can play around with
my with the models i have of the world
and the cost functions right and i can
hack my own cost functions which means i
have a little bit of free will but
as much as i want to do stuff in the
universe i don't think i could suddenly
say
i mean actually this is ridiculous
because now i say i could try and do it
right it's like i'm suddenly give up
everything and become a rapper tomorrow
right maybe i i could try that but i
don't have sufficient um agency to make
that necessarily happen i'm on a
trajectory so when in dragon's lair i
know that i have some trajectories that
i can play with
where where sartre realized he thought
that he had no assembly no memory he
could just leap across and do everything
and nietzsche said okay
i realize i don't have full freedom but
i have some freedom
and i and the assembly theory basically
says that it says if you have these
constraints in your past they limit what
you were able to do in the future but
you can use them to do amazing things
let's say i'm a poppy plant and i'm
creating some opiates
opiates are really interesting molecules
i mean they're obviously great for
medicine great product cause great
problems in society but let's let's
imagine we fast forward a billion years
what will opiate the opioids look like
in a billion years well we can guess
because we can see how those proteins
will evolve and we can see how the
secondary metabolites will change
and but they can't go radical they can't
they can't suddenly become i don't know
like
a molecule that you find in the oled in
a display
they will have some they will be limited
by their the causal chain that produced
them
and that's what i'm getting at saying
you're
we're predictive we are
unpredictably predictable or predictably
unpredictable predictably unpredictable
within a constraint on the trajectory
we're on yeah so the predictably part is
the this is the constraints of the
trajectory and the unpredictable part
is the part that you still haven't
really clarified the origin of uh
of the little bit of freedom yeah so
you're you're just arguing you're you're
basically saying that
radical freedom
is impossible you're you're really
operating in a world of constraints that
are constrained by the memory of the
trajectory of the chemistry that led to
who you are okay but
uh you know even just a tiny bit of
freedom
even if everything if everywhere
you are
in cages
if you can move around in that cage a
little bit yeah you're free
i agree and so the question is
in assembly theory
if we're thinking about free will
where does the little bit of freedom
come from what is the i
that can decide to be a rapper what why
what is that that's a cute little trick
we've convinced
each other of so we can
do fun tricks at parties or is there
something fundamental that allows us to
feel free to be free
i think that that's the question that i
want to answer i know you want to answer
it and i think it's so profound i'd
let me have a go at it i would say that
i don't take the stance of sam harris
because i think sam harris when he said
the way he says it is almost it's really
interesting i'd love to talk to him
about it sam harris almost thinks
himself out of existence right because
because
do you know what i mean yeah well i mean
he has different views on consciousness
versus free will i think he saves
himself with consciousness he thinks
himself out of existence with free will
yeah yeah exactly so that means there's
no point right
so he's a leaf floating on a river
yeah uh um i i think that
he he he's i don't know i'd love to ask
him whether he really believes that and
then we could play some games oh yeah no
no i then would say i'll get him to play
a game of cards with me and i'll work
out the conditions on which he says no
and then i'll get him to the conditions
he says yes and then i'll trap him in
his logical inconsistency with that
argument
because at some point at some point when
he loses enough money or the prospect of
losing enough money
um
there's a way of basically mapping out a
series of
so what what what will is about let's
not call it free will that what will us
about is to have a series of
decisions equally weighted in front of
you
and those decisions aren't necessarily
energy minimization those decisions
are a function of the model you've made
in your mind you're in your simulation
and the way you've interacted in reality
and also
other interactions you're having with
other individuals and happenstance
and
i think that you have there's a little
bit of delay in time so i think what
what you're able to do is say well i'm
going to do the counterfactual
i've done all of them
and i'm going to i'm gonna go this way
and you probably don't know why i think
free will is actually very complex
interaction between your conscious
your unconscious and your conscious
brain
and i think the reason why we're arguing
about it so it's so interesting in the
and we just some people
um outsource their free will to that
unconscious brain
and some people try and
overthink the free will in the conscious
brain
i would say that
sam harris has realized his conscious
brain doesn't have free will but his
unconscious brain does
that's my guess right and that he can't
have access to the unconscious yeah and
that's kind of annoying and but then so
he's just he's going to through
meditation come to acceptance with that
fact yeah just which is maybe okay i
maybe but i do think that i have
the ability to make decisions and i like
my decisions in fact i mean this is an
argument i have with
with uh some people that um some days i
feel i have no free will and it's just
an illusion and this is one and it makes
me more radical if you like you know as
a
i get to explore more of the state space
and i'm like i'm going to try and affect
the world now i'm really going to ask
the question that maybe i dare not ask
or dare not or do the thing i dare not
do
and that allows me to kind of explore
more it's funny that um
if you truly accept that there's no free
will
that is a kind of radical freedom
it's funny
but you're because
the little bit of the illusion in under
that
framework that you have that you can
make choices
if choice is just an illusion of
psychology
you can do whatever the hell you want
that's the but we don't do we and i
think but because you don't truly accept
that
you you think that there's
like you think there's a choice which is
why
you don't uh just do whatever the hell
you want like you feel like there's some
responsibility for making the wrong
choice which is why you don't do it but
if you truly accept that the choice has
already been made
then you can go
i don't know what is the most radical
thing
um i mean but
yeah i don't i wonder what what am i
preventing myself from doing that i
would really want to do um
probably like humor stuff like
i would
i would love to if i could like save a
game
do the thing and then reload it later
like do undo it'd probably be humor just
just to do something like super
hilarious
[Laughter]
that's super embarrassing and then just
go i mean it's basically just fun i
would add more fun to the world i mean i
sometimes do that because i you know um
i sometimes um
i try and i try and mess up my reality
in unusual ways by just doing things
because i'm bored but not bored i'm not
expressing this very well i think that
this is a really interesting problem
that perhaps the hard sciences don't
really understand that they are
responsible for because
the question about how life emerged and
how intelligence emerges and
consciousness and free will they're all
ultimately boiling down to some of the
same mechanics i think
my feeling is that they are
the same problem again and again and
again
the transition from a
you know a a boring world or a world in
which there is no selection so i wonder
if free will has something to do with
selection and models and and also the
models you're generating the brain and
also your the amount of memory your
working memory have available any one
time to generate counter factuals well
that's fascinating so the decision
making process
is a kind of selection yeah that could
be just absolutely yet another
you get another manifestation of the
selection mechanism that's uh pervasive
throughout the universe okay that's
fascinating to think about
yeah there's not some kind of
fundamental its own thing or something
like that
that is just yet another example of
selection yeah
and in the universe that's intrinsically
open you want to do that because you
generate novelty you mentioned something
about
do cellular automata exist outside the
human mind
in our little offline conversation
um why is that an interesting question
so uh cellular automata complexity
what's the relationship between
complexity and the human mind
and uh trees falling in the forest
infrastructure so the ca so when john
von neumann and conway and feynman were
doing ca's doing on paper ca is cellular
just drawing them on paper
how awesome is that that they were doing
cellular automata on paper yeah and then
they were doing a computer that takes
like forever to print out anything and
program sure people are now with the
tick tock kids these days with the tick
tock
don't understand how amazing it is to
just play with cellular automata
arbitrarily changing the rules as you
want the initial conditions and see the
beautiful
patterns emerge sing with fractals all
of them
all you've just given me a brilliant
idea i wonder if there's a tick tock
account that's just dedicated to putting
out ca rules and if it isn't we should
make one
100
and now we'll get so we have millions of
views like millions yes no you'll get uh
you'll get dozens just have it running
i'm saying look i i kind of
ca i love cas
uh
yeah no i just
we
a few years ago i made some robots that
talk to each other chemical robots that
played the game of hex
um invented by john nash
um by doing chemistry and they
communicated by twitter
which experiments they were doing and
they had a they had a they had a they
had a look up table of experiments and
robot one said i'm doing experiment 10.
and the others wrote about okay i'll do
experiment one then and then communicate
via twister and then publicly or yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh
can you maybe quickly explain what the
game of hex is uh yes so it's a
basically a bought a hexagonal board and
you try and basically you color each
hexagon each element on the board it's
hexagon and you try and get from one
side to the other and the other one
tries to block you wait uh how are they
connected uh so what they're wrote
uh yeah let's go back so they wrote two
robots yeah each robot was doing die
chemistry so making rgb red green blue
red green blue red green blue and they
could just choose from experiments to do
red green blue um initially i said to my
group we need to make two chemical
robots that play chess and my group were
like
that's too hard no complicated go away
um but anyways we had the robot
people listening to this uh should
probably know that lee cronin is a as a
amazing group of brilliant people
he's exceptionally well published he's
written a huge number of amazing papers
whenever
he uh calls himself stupid and is is a
sign of humility and i deeply respect
that and appreciate it so people
listening to this should know this is
this is a world-class scientist who
doesn't take him so seriously which i
really appreciate and love anywho you
talking about serious science
we're back to uh
your group rejecting your idea of
chemical robots playing chess
via
dies
so you went to a simpler game of hex
okay so what else the team that did it
were brilliant i really think
the i think they still have ptsd from
doing it because i said this is a
workshop what i'd often do is i'd so i
have about 60 people on my team
and occasionally before lockdown i would
say
i'm a bit bored we're gonna we're gonna
have a workshop on something who wants
to come and then basically about 20
people turn up to my office and i say
we're gonna do this mad thing
and then it would just self organize and
some of them were like no i'm not doing
this and then you get lu you get left
with the the happy dozen yeah and what
we did is we built this robot and doing
die chemistry is really easy you can
just take two molecules react them
together and change color
and what i wanted to do is have a
palette of different molecules you could
react commentarily and get different
colors so you've got two robots and i
went wouldn't it be cool if the robots
basically shared the same list of
reactions to do and they said oh and
because then you could do a kind of
multi-core
chemistry like they weren't so you have
two chemical reactions going on at once
and they could basically outsource the
problem but they're sharing the same
tape exactly okay so robot one would say
i'm gonna do i'm gonna do experiment one
and the other robot says how to
experiment 100. and then they co they
cross it off but i wanted to make it
that's brilliant by the way that is
genius sorry well i wanted to make it
groovier and i said look let's have him
competing yeah to make to so playing a
game of hex and so when the robot does
it does an experiment and the more blue
the die the more it gets the the chart
the higher chance it gets to make the
move it wants on the hex board
so if it gets a red color it's like it
gets down weighted in the other robot
and so what the robots could do is they
play each player move
and because the fitness function or the
the optimization function was to make
the color blue they started to invent um
reactions we didn't weren't on the list
and they did this by not cleaning
because we made cleaning optional so
when one robot realized if it didn't
clean its pipes it could get blue more
quickly yeah and the other robot
realized that so it's like getting dirty
as well and they
unintend the consequences of super
intelligence okay
but that was the game and we
communicating through twitter though
they were they were doing it through
twitter and twitter blamed them a couple
of times i said come on you've got a
couple of robots doing chemistry it's
really cool stop banning them yeah but
and then in the end they have we had to
take them off twitter and they just
communicated virus server because it was
just there were people saying you could
still find it cronin lab 1 and cronin
lab 2 on twitter and it was like make
move wait you know mix a and b wait 10
seconds yeah answer blue you know i i
really find it super compelling that
you would have a chemical entity
that's communicating with the world
that was one of the things i want to do
in my origin of life reaction right is
basically have a
have a reactor
that's basically just randomly
enumerating through chemical space and
have some kind of cycle
and then read out what the molecules
reading out using a mass spectrometer
and then convert that to text and
publish it on twitter
and then wait until it says i'm alive
reckon that would i reckon that that
twitter account will get a lot of
followers yeah and i'm still trying to
convince my group that we should just
make an origin of life twitter account
where it's going
to be like hello testing
i'm here
well i'll share it i like it i
particularly enjoy this idea
of a non-human entity communicating with
the world via a human designed social
network it's quite a
quite a beautiful idea
how we were talking about
uh ca's existing outside the human mind
yeah so i really admire stephen wolfram
i think he's a genius clearly
a genius and trapped in his actually
it's like a problem with being so smart
is you get trapped in your own you know
mind right
and i've i tried to actually i tried to
convince stephen that assembly theory
wasn't nonsense he was like no it's just
nonsense
i was a little bit sad by that so
nonsense applied even if we applied to
the simple surprise construct of a
one-dimensional cellular automata for
example yeah yeah but i mean actually
maybe i'm doing myself a bit too down it
was it was like it was just as a theory
was coming through and i didn't really
know how to explain it but but we are
going to use assembly theory cas instead
of automata but i'm i wanted to
what i was really curious about is why
people are marvel i mean you marvel at
cas and their complexity and i say well
hang on that complexity is baked in
because
if you play the game of life
in a ca you have to run it on a computer
like you have to have a you have to do a
number of operations put in the boundary
conditions so is it surprising that you
get this structure out is it
manufactured by the boundary conditions
and and it is interesting because i
think i said um
cetera automata running them
uh is teaching me something about what
real numbers are and aren't
and i haven't quite got there yet i was
playing on the airplane coming over and
just realized i have no idea what real
numbers are really
and they'll say well i do actually have
some notion what real numbers are
um
and i think
thinking about real numbers as functions
rather than numbers is more appropriate
and then if you then apply that to cas
then you're saying well actually
um why am i seeing this complexity in
this in this rule
is it is it you know is it is it deter
you've got this deterministic system and
yet you get this incredible structure
coming out well
isn't that what you'd get with any real
number as you
as you apply as a function
and you're trying to read it out to an
arbitrary position
and i wonder if cas are just helping me
well my my misunderstanding of cas might
be helping me understand them in terms
of real numbers i don't know what you
think yeah well the funk is
but
uh the devil's in the function
it's like which is the function that's
generating your real
number
like
that it seems like it's very important
the specific algorithm of that function
because some lead to something super
trivial some lead to something that's
all chaotic and some lead to things that
are
just walk that
fine line of complexity and we'll take a
look at structure i think we agree so
let's take it back a second so take the
logistic map or something logistic
equation
where you have this equation which is
um
you don't you don't know what's gonna
happen at n plus one but once you've
done n plus one you know full time you
can't predict it
for me cas and logistic equation feel
similar
and
and i think what's incredibly
interesting
and i share
your
kind of
wonder at running a ca
but also i'm saying well what is it
about the boundary conditions and the
way i'm running that calculation so in
my group with my team we actually made a
chemical ca we made game of life we
actually made a physical grid i haven't
been able to publish this paper it's
been trapped in purgatory for a long
time but we wrote up a paper how to do a
chemical formulation of the game of life
which we made a chemical computer and
one of little cells and i was playing
game of life with a bz reaction so each
cell would pulse on and off on and off
on and off we have little stirrer bars
and we have little gates yeah and we
actually played conway's game of life in
there and we got structures in that we
got structures in that game from the
chemistry that you wouldn't expect from
the actual ca
so that's kind of cool in the um because
they're they're they're interacting
outside of the cell smile or so what's
happening is you're getting noise so the
thing is
that you've got this bz reaction that
gives on off on off on off but there's
also a wake
and those wakes constructively interfere
or
in such a non-trivial way
that that's
non-deterministic
and the non-determinism in in in the
system gives very rich dynamics and i
was wondering if i could physically make
a chemical computer with this ca um that
gives me something different that i
can't get in a silicon
representation
of a ca where all the states are clean
because you don't have the noise
trailing into the next round you just
have the state so the the paper in
particular so it's just a beautiful idea
to use a chemical computer to construct
the cellular automata and the famous one
of game of life but it's also
interesting as a really interesting
scientific question of whether some kind
of random perturbations or some source
of randomness
can uh
have a uh
significant
constructive effect on the complexity of
the system and indeed
i mean whether it's random or just
non-deterministic and can we bake in
that non-determinism at the beginning
you know i wonder what what is the i'm
trying to think about what is the
encoding space the encoding space is
pretty big we have
um 49 stir ups of 49 cells 49 chem bits
all connected to one another in like an
analog computer but being read out
discretely as they come the bz reaction
so just to say the bz reaction is a
chemical oscillator and what happens in
each cell is it goes between red and
blue so two russians discovered it blues
off zapakinsky i think luzov first
proposed it and everyone said you're
crazy it breaks the second law and
zabasinski said no it doesn't break the
second law it's consuming a fuel
and so and then and and it's a like
there's a lot of uh um uh chemistry
hidden in the russian literature
actually that just because
russians just wrote it in russian they
didn't publish in english speaking
journalism it's heartbreaking actually
yeah it's
yeah sad and
it's great it's there right it's not
lost i'm sure we will find a way of
translating it properly well the
silver lining slash greater sadness of
all of this is there's probably ideas in
in english speaking like there's ideas
in certain disciplines
that
if discovered by other disciplines
would crack open some of the biggest
mysteries in those disciplines like
computer science for example it's
uh
trying to solve
problems like nobody else has ever tried
to solve problems
as as if it's not already been all
addressed in cognitive science and
psychology mathematics in physics
and uh just whatever you want to
economics even but if if you look into
that literature you might be able to
just discover some beautiful ideas
obviously russian is uh
is an interesting case of that's because
there's a lawson translation but he said
there's a source of
fuel source of energy yeah yeah so with
the bz reaction you have a you have a an
acid in there called malonic acid yeah
and what happens is it it when it react
when it
power it's basically like a battery that
powers it
and it loses co2 so decarboxylates it's
just a chemical reaction what that means
we have to do is continuously feed or we
just keep the bz reaction going in a in
a long enough time so it's it's like
it's reversible in time
but only like yeah
but um but it's fascinating i mean the
team that did it i'm really proud of
their persistence we made a we made a
chemical computer um
it can solve little problems it can
solve travelling salesman problems
actually nice um but like i said it's co
it's not any faster than a regular
computer is there is there something you
can do maybe i'm not sure
i'm not i think we can come up with a
way of solving problems
also really complex hard ones
um
because it's an analog computer and we
can we can
the it can energy minimize really
quickly it doesn't have to basically go
through every element in the matrix
like
flip it it just reads out so we can
actually do monte carlo by just
shaking the box
it's literally a box shaker
you don't actually have to encode the
shaking of the box in a silicon memory
and then just shuffle everything around
yeah and you can tell analog it's
natural so
it's a uh it's an organic computer
yeah yeah so we're so i was playing
around with this and i was kind of
annoying some of my colleagues i'm
wondering if we could get to chemical
supremacy like quantum supremacy and i
kind of calculated how big
the
grid has to be so we can actually start
to solve problems faster than the
silicon computer but i'm not willing to
um to state how that is yet because i'm
probably wrong it's not that i'm it's
any top secret thing is i want i think i
can make a chemical computer that can
solve optimization problems faster than
the silicon computer
that's fascinating and but then you're
unsure how big that has to be yeah i
think i mean it might be a big box hard
to shake it might be exactly a big box
hard to shake and basically a bit sloppy
did we answer the the question about uh
do uh cellular exist outside the mind
we didn't but i would i would posit that
they don't
and i i and
but i think minds can well so the mind
is fundamental
what's the what i mean well i mean sorry
let's go to the back so as a physical
phenomena do cas exist in physical
reality right i would say they probably
don't exist outside the human mind but
now i've constructed them they exist in
computer memories they exist in my lab
they exist on paper so they are they
emerge from the human mind
i'm just interested in because stephen
wolfram likes cas a lot of people like
cas and likes to think of them as
minimal computational elements
i'm just saying well do they exist in
reality or are they a representation of
a simple machine that's just very
elegant to implement
so it's a platonic question i guess yeah
i mean it's
there's initial conditions
there's a memory in the system
there are simple rules that dictate the
evolution of the system
so what exists the idea the rules the
yeah people are using cas as models for
things in reality to say hey
look you can you can do this thing in a
ca
and my my when i see this i'm saying oh
that's cool but what does that tell me
about reality where's the ca in in space
right it's a mathematical object so for
people who don't know cellular automata
there's a is usually a grid whether it's
one-dimensional two-dimensional or
three-dimensional and it evolves by
simple local rules like you die or born
if the neighbors
are alive or dead and
it turns out if you have
with certain kinds of initial conditions
and with certain kinds of very simple
rules you can uh create like arbitrarily
complex and beautiful systems and to me
um
you know whether uh
drugs are involved or not i can sit back
for hours and enjoy the
the mystery of it how such complexity
emerges
it gives me almost like you know people
talk about religious experiences
it gives me a sense
that you get to
have a glimpse
at the uh
origin of this whole thing
whatever is creating
this
complexity from such simplicity
is the very thing that brought my mind
to life
this me the human
uh our our human civilization
and
yes
those constructs are pretty trivial
they're
i mean that's part of their magic is
even in this trivial
framework you could see the emergence or
especially in this trivial framework you
could see the emergence of complexity
from simplicity i guess what lee you're
saying is that
this is not you know
um
this is
highly unlike
systems we've seen the physical world
even though they probably carry some of
the same
magic like mechanistically
i mean i'm saying that the the the
operating system that ca has to exist on
is quite complex right
and so i wonder if you're getting the
complexity out of the ca from the
boundary conditions the operating system
the underlying digital computer oh wow
so you those are some strong words
against ca's then i didn't know again i
mean i'm in the i'm in love with cas as
well right i'm just saying
they aren't as trivial as people think
they are incredible
you get to that richness you have to
iterate billions of times
and you need a display
and you need a math coprocessor and you
need a von neumann machine
based on a turing machine with digital
error correction and states wow to think
that for the simplicity of a grid
you're basically saying a grid is not
simple yeah
it requires incredible complexity to
bring a grid to life yeah
yeah that's what then what is simple
that's all i wanted to say i agree with
you with a wonder of cas i just think
but remember this we take so much for
granted what the ca is resting on
because von neumann and and uh firemen
weren't showing weren't seeing these
elaborate structures they could not get
that far
yeah but that's the limitation of their
mind yeah exactly
but i i think that's
the question is
whether the essential elements of the
cellular automata
is um
is present
without all the complexities required to
build a computer
the reason i find it incredible is that
yeah my intuition is yes it might look
different
uh there might not be a grill structure
a grid like structure
but
local interactions operating under
simple rules
and resulting in
multi-hierarchical
complex structures feels like a thing
that's doesn't require a computer i
agree but coming back to von neumann and
feynman and wolfram
their their minds the non-trivial minds
to create those architectures and do it
and
to put on those
state transitions
and i think that something that's really
incredibly interesting
that um is understanding how the human
mind builds those straight those state
transition machines
you i could see how deeply in love with
the idea of memory you are so it's it's
like
how much of e equals mc squared
like
is more than an equation it has albert
einstein in it
like you're saying like you can't just
say this is a
uh like
the equations of physics are a really
good
simple capture
of a physical phenomena it is also
has the mem that equation has the memory
of the humans
absolutely
absolutely yeah
but i don't i don't know if you're
implying this i don't uh that's a
beautiful
idea but i don't know if
i'm comfortable with that
sort of diminishing the power of that
equation no no it causes built on the
shoulders it enhances i think it
enhances it it's not that equation is a
minimal compressed representation of
reality right we can use machine
learning or or max tech marks um ai
firemen to find lots of solutions for
gravity but isn't it wonderful that the
laws that we do find are the maximally
compressed representations
yeah but that representation you can now
give it as
i guess the universe has the memory of
einstein with that representation
but then you can now give it as a gift
for free yeah yeah it's very memorable
civilizations i had to go through a lot
of pain together but it's low memory so
physic i say that physics and chemistry
and biology are the same discipline
they're just physics
laws in physics there's no such thing as
a law in physics it's just low memory
stuff
because you've got low memory stuff you
can things reoccur quickly
as you get build in more memory you get
to chemistry so things become more
contingent when you get to biology more
contingent still and then technology so
the more memory you need the more that
your laws are local
that's all i'm saying and that the
the less memory the more the laws are
universal because they're not laws they
are just low memory states
we have to talk about
a thing you've kind of mentioned already
a bunch of times but
doing computation
through chemistry chemical based
computation
i've seen you
refer to it as
in in a sexy title of
kemp
mutation computation
so what is computation what is
chemically uh chemical based computation
okay so computation is a a name i gave
to the process of
um building a state machine to make any
molecule physically in the lab
and so as a chemist chemists make
molecules by hand
and um
and they're quite hard chemists have a
lot of tacit knowledge a lot of
ambiguity
it's not possible to go uniformly to the
literature and read a recipe to make a
molecule
and then go and make it in the lab
every time some recipes are better than
others but they all assume
some
knowledge
and it's not universal what that is like
so it's uh carried from
from human to human yeah some of that
implicit knowledge and you're saying can
we remove the humor from the picture can
we like uh program
by the way what is a state machine
so a state machine is a i suppose a
a a object either abstract or mechanical
where you can do
you can
um do a unit operation on it and flick
it from one state to another so a turn
style would be a good example of a state
machine
uh there's some kinds of states and some
kind of transitions between states and
it's um
very
formal in nature in terms of like it's
precise yes you can mathematically
precisely
describe a state machine so i mean you
know a very simple boolean
um gates are a very good way of building
kind of logic based state machines
obviously a turing machine the concept
of a turing machine where you have a
tape and a read head and a series of
rules in a table and you would basically
look at what's on the tape
and if you're shifting the tape from
left to right and if you see a zero or
one you look in your lookup table and
say right i've seen a zero and a one um
i then do
i then respond to that so the turn style
would be is there a human being pushing
the turnstile
in direction clockwise
if yes i will open let them go if it's
anti-clockwise no so yes so state
machine has some labels and a transition
transition diagram
so you're looking to
come up with a
chemical computer to form state machines
to to create molecules or yeah so
which
what's the chicken in the egg so
computation is not a chemical computer
because we talked a few moments about
actually doing computations with
chemicals yeah what i'm now saying is i
want to use state machines to transform
chemicals and so so build chemicals
programmatically yeah i mean i get in
trouble saying this i i said to my my
group oh i shouldn't say it because this
but i said look we should make the
crackbot is it in the crack robot the
real what the mixture the crackpot
oh
crackbot the robot that makes crack but
maybe we should scrub this from
but
or uh well so maybe you can educate me
on uh breaking bad with like maths right
yeah so in breaking bad you want to make
you want to make um
basically some kind of
mix of ex machina and breaking bad
no i don't i don't i record i don't but
you don't i said that's what i'm going
to do once you release the papers
but i shaved my head
and i'm going to uh
live a life of crime anyway i'm sorry no
no um so so yeah let's get back to so
indeed it is about making drugs but
importantly making important drugs
um
so drugs matter yeah but let's go let's
go back so
the basic thesis is chemistry is very
analog
there is no state machine
um
and i wandered into the
through the paper walls in the in the
japanese house a few years ago and said
okay hey organic chemist why are you why
are you doing this analog they said well
chemistry is really hard you ha you
can't automate it it's impossible
i said but
is it impossible says yeah and they said
they said you know i got the impression
they were saying it's magic
and so when people tell me things are
magic
it's like no no they can't be magic
right so let's break this down and so
what i did is um i went to my my group
one day
about about eight years ago and said hey
guys i've written this new programming
language for you
um and so everything is clear and you
know you have to you're not allowed to
just wander around the lab willy-nilly
you have to pick up things in order go
to the balance at the right time and all
this stuff and they looked at me as if i
was insane and basically kicked me out
of the lab and said no don't do that
we're not doing that yeah and i said
okay so i went back the next day and
said
i'm gonna find some money so we can make
cool robots do chemical reactions
everyone went that's cool yeah
and so in that process
the first to try to convert the humans
to become robots and
next you agree you might as well just
create the robots yes but so in that in
the formalization process yeah so what i
did i said look a react chemical to make
a molecule you need to do four things
abstractly i want to make a chemical
turing machine because a turing machine
you think about this imagine a turing
machine turing machine is the ultimate
abstraction of of a computation because
it's been shown by turing in others that
basically a universal turing machine
should be able to do all computations
that you can imagine it's like wow
why don't i think of a turing machine
for chemistry let's think of a magic
robot that can make any molecule
let's think about that for a second okay
great how do we then implement it and i
think it's right so what is the
abstraction so to do
to make any molecule you have to do a
reaction so you have to put reagents
together do a reaction
in a flask
typically then you after the reaction
you have to stop the reactions you do
what's called a workup so whatever cool
it down add some liquid to it extract so
then after you do the workup you
separate so you then remove the molecule
separate them all out and then the final
step is purification so reaction uh work
up separate purify so this is basically
like my exactly like a um a turing
machine where you have your tape you
have your tape head you have some rules
and then you run it so i thought cool
i went to all the chemists and said look
chemistry isn't that hard reaction work
up separation purification do that in
cycles forever for any molecule all the
chemistry
done
and they said um chemistry is that hard
i said but but just in principle and i
got a few very enlightened people to say
yeah okay in principle but it ain't
gonna work
and this was in about 2013 2014
and i
i found myself going to an architecture
conference almost by accident it's like
why i'm at this random conference on
architecture
and that was because i published a paper
on inorganic architecture and they said
come to the architecture conference but
the inorganic architecture nano
architecture it's not and i went okay
and then i found these guys at the
conference 3d printing ping-pong balls
and shapes and this is through it 3d
printing was cool and it's like this is
ridiculous why are you 3d printing ping
pong balls and i gave them a whole load
of abuse like i normally do when i first
meet people how to win friends and
influence people and then i was like oh
my god you guys are geniuses yeah and so
i got from they were a bit confused
because i was calling them idiots and
then call them geniuses it's like
will you come to my lab and we're going
to build a robot to do chemistry with a
3d printer and say well that's cool all
right
so i had them come to the lab and we
started to 3d print test tubes so you
imagine you know 3d printer bottle and
then and then and then use the same
gantry to basically rather than to
squirt out
plastic out of a nozzle have a little
syringe and chemicals in so we had the
3d printer that could simultaneously
print the test tube and then put
chemicals into the test tube
and then oh it says really end to end
yeah i was like that'll be because
they've got g-code to do it all it's
like yeah that's cool so i got my group
doing this and i developed it a bit and
i realized that we could take those unit
operations and we built a whole bunch of
pumps and valves and i realized that i
could basically take the literature
and i made the first version of the
computer in 2016-17
i made some architectural decisions so i
designed the pumps and valves in my
group i did all the electronics in my
group they were brilliant
i
i cannot pay tribute to my group enough
in doing this they were just brilliant
and there were some poor souls there
that said lee
why are you making us design electronics
i'm like well because i don't understand
it
like so you're making us design stuff
because you don't understand it's like
yeah it's like but can we not just buy
some
i said well we can but then i don't
understand how to you know
what bus they're gonna use and the
serial ports and all this stuff i just
wanted and i made i came up the decision
to design a bunch of pumps and valves
and use power of the ethernet so you've
got one cable for power and data plug
them all in plug them all into a router
and um and then i made the state machine
and there was a couple of cool things i
did all they did actually um
we got the the abstraction so reaction
uh work up separation um purification
and then i
made the decision to do it in batch
now as in batch
all chemistry had been digitized before
apparently every once it's been done but
everyone's been doing it in flow
and flow is continuous and there are
infinity is everywhere and you have to
just and i realized
that i could actually make a state
machine where i basically put stuff in
the reactor
turn it up from one state to another
state stop it and just read it out and
okay and i was kind of bitching at
electrical engineers saying you have it
easy you don't have to clean out the
electrons you know because electrons
don't leave a big mess they leave some
em waste but in my state machine i built
in cleaning so it's like would do all
operation then it cleans the backbone
then can do it again so there's no
there's any so what we managed to do
over a couple of years is is develop the
hardware develop state machine and we
encoded three molecules we did three the
first three we did nitol sleeping drug
rafinomide anti-seizure and viagra
you know and i i could make jokes on the
paper it's a hard problem blah blah blah
yeah that's very good
and then and then in the next one what
we did said okay my poor organic chemist
said look lee
we've we've worked with you this long
we've made a robot that looks like it's
going to take our jobs away
and
and not just take our jobs away that
what we love in the lab but now we have
to become programmers but we're not even
good programmers we just have to spend
ages writing lines of code
that are boring and it's not as elegant
and when you're right
so then
but i knew because i had this
abstraction
and i knew that there was language
i could suddenly develop a state machine
that would interpret the language which
was lossy and ambiguous and populate my
abstraction so i built a chemical
programming language that is is actually
going to be recursively enumerable it's
going to be a turing complete language
actually which is kind of cool which
means it's formally verifiable
so
where we are now is we can now read the
literature using a bit of natural
language processing it's not the best
that many other groups have done better
job but we can use that language reading
to populate the state machine
and basically add subtract there's a
we've got about
a number of primitives
that we
the
you know
basically program loops that we dovetail
together and we can make any molecule
with it okay so that's that's the kind
of program synthesis so you start like
literally you talk about like a paper
like a scientific paper
that's being read
from natural language processing
extracting
some kind of uh details about chemical
reactions and the the chemical
molecules and composites involved
and then that's
that uh in gpt
terms serves as a prompt
for the program synthesis that's kind of
trivial right now there you have a bunch
of different like for loops and so on
that creates a program in this
chemical language that can then be
interpreted by the
chemical computer
uh the computer yeah chem kickstarter
yeah
everything sounds better in your uh
british accent but it's i love it so the
into the computer and that's able to
then
basically be a 3d printer
for these for molecules yeah i wouldn't
call it a 3d printer i would call it a
universal chemical reaction system
because 3d printing gives the wrong
impression but yeah and and it purifies
and the nice thing is that that code now
that we call it chem the kdl code
is
is really interesting because
now so computation what is computation
computation is
what computing is to mathematics i think
computation is the process of taking
chemical code and some input reagents
and making the same molecule making the
molecule
reproducibly every time without fail
well it's computation it's the process
of taking a using a program to take some
input conditions and give you an output
same every time
right reliably
so the the problem is now maybe you can
push back and correct me on this
so i know biology is messy
my question is how messy is chemistry so
the if we use the analogy of a computer
it's easier to make
computation in a computer
very precise that it's repeatable
it makes errors almost never if it does
the exact same way over and over and
over and over what about chemistry is
there messiness in the whole thing it
can that be somehow leveraged can it be
controlled can be that removed do we
want to remove it from the system oh yes
no right is there messiness
there
there is messiness because chemistry is
like you're you're you're doing
reactions on on billions of molecules
and they don't always work but you've
got purification there
and so what we've found is at the
beginning everyone said it can't work
it's gonna be too messy it'll just fail
and i said but you managed to get
chemistry to work in the lab are you
magic are you doing something
so i would say
now go back to the first ever computer
or the eniac
five million soldered joints
400 000 uh valves that are exploding all
the time was that would you have gone
okay that's messy
so we've got the and
have we got the equivalent of the aniak
in my lab
we've got 15 computers in the lab now
and they are they unreliable yeah they
fall apart here and there but are they
getting better
really quickly yeah are they now able to
reliably make are we at the point in the
lab where there are some molecules we
would rather make on the computer
than have a human being make yeah we've
just done we've just made a
um anti-influenza molecule and some
antivirals
um six steps on the computer that would
take a human being
about one week to make arbor doll
um of continuous labor and all they do
now is load up the reagents press go
button and just go away and drink coffee
wow so this i mean
and this is uh you're saying this
computer is just the early days and so
like some of the criticisms just have to
do with the early days and yes i would
say that something like this is
uh
quite impossible
uh you know so the fact that you're
doing is is incredible not not
impossible of course but extremely
difficult it it did seem really
difficult and i do keep pinching myself
when i go in the lab i was like is it
working like yep and it it's not you
know it does clog
it does stop you've got to clean this is
great
you know but it's um it's getting more
reliable because i made some we just
made design decisions and said we are
not going to abandon the abstraction
think about it if the if you the von
neumann
implementation was abandoned i mean
think about what we do to semiconductors
to really constrain them to um what we
do to silicon in a fab lab
we take computation for granted silicon
is not in its natural state we are
doping the hell out of it it's
incredible what they're able to
accomplish and achieve that reliability
at the scale they do like you said
that's after moore's law we'll have now
and
so where we you know
uh
how it started you know now we started
at the bottom now we're here we have
only have 20 million molecules say 20
million molecules in one database maybe
a few hundred million in all the
pharmaceutical companies
um and those few hundred million
molecules are responsible for all the
drugs that we've had in humanity except
you know biologics for the last 50 years
now imagine what happens when a drug
goes out of print
it goes out of prints because there's
only a finite number of manufacturing
facilities in the world that make these
drugs is that a print yeah isn't that
computer the printing press the for
chemistry yeah
and and not only that we can protect the
kdl so we can stop bad actors doing it
we can encrypt them
and we can give people that's the name
of sorry to interrupt is the name of the
programming language the kydl is the
name of the programming language and the
pro code we give the chemicals so chi as
in you know just for it's like a it's
actually like an xml format but i've now
taken it from script to a
to a fully
expressible programming language so we
can do dynamics and there's four loops
in there and conditional statements
right but the structure it started out
as a um
like a like an xml thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah and now we also the chemist doesn't
need to program in kdl they can just go
to the software and type in add a to b
reflux do what they would normally do
and you just convert it to kindly l and
they have a linter to check it and
everything how do you um
you know not with ascii but because it's
a greek letter how do you go with
um how do you spell it just using the
english alphabet we're just like
xdl but all we use we put in kai and it
was named by one of my students and i
and one of my postdocs many years ago
and i quite liked it it's like
it's important i think when the team are
contributing to such big ideas because
their ideas as well isn't i try not to
just rename i didn't call it cronin or
anything that because they keep saying
you know is a
is it the the chemistry when they're
putting stuff in the computer one of my
students said we're asking now is it
cronin complete and i was like what does
that mean i said well can we make it on
the damn machine
and i was like oh is that is that a
compliment or a majority but they're
like well
it might be both
yeah so you tweeted quote why does
chemistry need a universal programming
language question mark
for all the reasons you can think of
reliability interoperability
collaboration remove ambiguity lower
cost increase safety open up discovery
molecular customization and publication
of executable chemical code
which is fascinating by the way just
publish code
and um
can you maybe elaborate a little bit
more about this kai dl
what does the universal language of
chemistry look like
a crone and
complete language it's a true incomplete
language really it's um but um so what
it has it has a series of operators in
it like add
heat stir
um
so there's a bunch of just unit
operations and all it is really is just
uh it's with chemical engineers why i
talked about this that you've just re
you've just you've just rediscovered
chemical engineering and i said well
yeah i know i said well
that's you know that's trivial i said
well well not real well yes it is
trivial and that's why it's good because
we've not only have we just got
rediscovered chemical engineering we've
made it implementable on universal
hardware that doesn't cost very much
money
and so the kdl has a series of
statements like define the reactor so it
defines
the reagents so they're all labels so
you assign them
and what we i also implemented at the
beginning is because i give all the
hardware i p address you put it on a
graph
and so what it does is like the graph is
equivalent to the the process of
firmware
the processor code so when you take your
kdl
and you go to run it on your computer
you can run it on any compatible
hardware in any configuration says
what's your what's your graph look like
as long as i can solve the problem on
the graph with these unit operations you
have the resources available compile
chem piles
[Laughter]
all right we can carry on for years i
but it is really it's compilation and
evolution and what it now does is it
says okay the problem we have before is
it was possible to do robotics for
chemistry but the robots were really
expensive they were unique they had
and what i want to do is to make sure
that every chemist in the world can get
access to machinery like this at
virtually no cost because it makes it
safer it makes it more reliable and then
if you go to the literature and you find
a molecule that could potentially cure
cancer
and let's say the molecule that could
potentially cure cancer takes you three
years to repeat
and maybe a student finishes their phd
in the time and they never get it back
um so it's really hard to
to kind of get all the way to that
molecule and it limits the ability of
humanity to build on it
if they just download the code and can
execute it it turns
i would say the electronic laboratory
notebook in chemistry is a data
symmetry
because no one will ever reproduce it
for now the data cemetery is a jupiter
notebook and you can just execute it and
people can play with it yeah the access
to it reverses the magnet huge is
increased
uh we'll talk about the so as with all
technologies
i think there's way more exciting
possibilities but they're also
terrifying possibilities and we'll talk
about all of them but let me just kind
of linger on the machine learning side
of this so you're describing programming
but
it's a language i don't know if you've
heard about open air codex which is uh
yeah i'm playing with it are you playing
of course you are
you really are rick from rick and morty
this is great okay uh
except philosophically d i mean he is i
guess kind of philosophically deep too
so for people who don't know gpt gpt3
that's the language model that can do
natural language generation so you can
give it a prompt and it can uh complete
the rest of it but it turns out that
that kind of prompt it's not just
completes the rest of it's generating
uh
like novel sounding text and then you
can apply that to generation of other
kinds of stuff
uh so these kinds of uh transformer
based language models are really good at
forming at uh uh forming deep
representations
of a particular space of like a medium
like language so you can then apply it
to a specific subset of language like
programming
so you can have it
learn the representation of the python
programming language and use it to then
generate
uh syntactically and semantically
correct
uh programs so you can start to make
progress on one of the hardest problems
in computer science which is program
synthesis how do you write programs that
accomplish different tasks
so what uh
openai codex does is it generate those
programs based on a
a prompt of some kind usually you can do
a natural language prompt so basically
as you do when you program you write
some
a comment which serves the basic
documentation of the inputs and the
outputs and the function of the
particular set of code and it's able to
generate that
point being is you can generate programs
using machine learning using neural
networks
those programs operate on the boring old
computer
can you generate programs that operate
there's got to be a clever version of
programs for this but uh can you write
programs that uh operate on a computer
yep there's actually software out there
right now we can go and do it
right so yeah it's a heuristic
it's rule based
but we have
what we've done
inspired by
codex actually is um over the summer i
ran a little workshop some of my groups
thought this inspired idea that we
should get a load of um
students and ask them to manually
collect data to label
chemical procedures into kdl
and um we have a called synth reader so
that so there's a lot bunch of people
doing this right now but they're doing
it without
uh abstraction
and because we have an abstraction
that's implementable in the hardware
um we've developed basically a chemical
analog of codecs
what you're doing we say sergeant trial
when you say abstraction in the hardware
what do you mean so right now a lot of
people doing machine learning and
reading chemistry and just and saying oh
you've all these operations add shake
whatever he
but they but because they don't have a
uniform
um i mean there's a couple of groups
doing it competitors actually and
they're good very good
but um
they can't run that code automatically
it they are losing
meaning
and and with and the really important
thing that you have to do is generate
context
and so what we've learned to do with our
abstraction is make sure we can pull the
context out of the text and so
can we take
a chemical procedure and read it and
generate our executable code yes
what's the hardest part about the whole
pipeline from the initial text
interpreting the initial text of a paper
extracting the meaningful context and
the meaningful chemical information to
then generating the the program to then
uh running that program in the hardware
what's what's the hardest part about
that pipeline as we look towards a
universal touring computer so the
hardest computer the heart the hardest
thing with the
uh the pipeline is that um
the software
the model gets confused
between some meanings right so if
you know chemists are very good at
inventing words that aren't broken down
so i would that the classic word that
you would use for boiling something is
called reflux so reflux is um you would
have a salt you'd have a solvent in a
round bottom flask at reflux it would be
boiling going up the reflux condenser
and coming down but that term reflux to
reflux could be changed you know to
people often make up words
new words and the and then the software
can fall over but what we've been able
to do is a bit like in python
or any programming language is identify
when things aren't matched so you
present the code you say this isn't
matched you may want to think about this
and then the user goes and says oh i
mean reflux and just ticks the box and
collects it so
what the codex or the chemex
uh
does in this case
is it just it
suggests the first go
and then the chemist goes and corrects
it and i really want the chemist to
correct it because
it's not safe i believe for for to allow
ai to just read literature and generate
code at this stage because now you're
having actual by the way chemex nice
uh
nice name uh
so you you are unlike
which is fascinating
if we live in a fascinating moment in
human history but yes you're
literally connecting ai
to some
physical
and
like it's building something in the
physical realm yeah especially in the
space of chemistry
that operates sort of
invisibly yeah
yeah i would say that's right
and it's it's really important to
understand those labeling schemes right
and one of the things i was never i was
always worried about the beginning that
the abstraction was going to fall over
and the way we did it was just by brute
force to start with we just kept reading
the literature and saying is there
anything new can we add a new rule in
and actually our kydl language expand
exploded
there was so many extra things we had to
keep adding and then i realized the
primitives still were maintained and i
could break them down again so
we get it's pretty good i mean there are
problems there problems of you know
interpreting any big sentence and
turning it into an actionable code and
then codex is not without its problems
you can you can crash it quite easily
right you can generate nonsense but boy
it's interesting i would love to learn
to program now using codex
right just hacking around right and i
wonder if chemist in the future will
learn to
do chemistry by just hacking around with
the system writing in different things
because the key thing that we're doing
with the chemistry is that where a lot
of mathematical chemistry went wrong is
people
and i think wolfram does this in
mathematica he assumes
that chemistry is a reaction where atom
a or molecule a reacts with molecule b
to give molecule c that's not what
chemistry is chemistry is take take some
molecule take a liquid and a solid
mix it up and heat it
and then extract it
so the programming language is actually
with respect to the process operations
and if you flick in process space
not in chemical graph space
you unlock everything because there's
only a finite number of processes you
need to do in chemistry
and that yeah and that's reassuring and
so so we're in the middle of it it's
really exciting um
it's not you know the be all on the end
or and there is like i say errors that
can creep in one day we might be able to
do it without human interaction you
simulate it and you'll know enough about
the simulation that will it the you know
i'm the lab won't catch fire but there
are so many safety issues right now that
we've got to really be very careful you
know protecting the user protecting the
environment protecting misuse i mean
there's lots to discuss
if you want to go down that route
because it's very very interesting you
don't want
another chocks being made or
or
explosives being made or or recreational
drugs being made but how do you stop a
molecular biologist making a drug that's
going to be important for them looking
at their you know particular
assay
on a bad actor
trying to make methamphetamine
i saw how you looked at me and you said
bad actor but that's exactly what i'm
going to do i'm trying to get the
details of this so i can be first oh
don't worry we can protect you from
yourself okay
um i'm not sure that's true but that
statement gives me hope
does
this ultimately excite you
about the future
or does it terrify you so
let's we mentioned that time is
fundamental
it seems like
you're at the cutting edge
of progress that will have to happen
that will happen
that there's no stopping it
and i as we've been talking about i see
obviously a huge number of exciting
possibilities
so whenever you automate
uh these kinds of things just the world
opens up it's like programming itself
and the computer a regular computer
has uh
created innumerable applications it made
the world
better in so many dimensions and it
created of course a lot of negative
things that we for some reason like to
focus on
using that very technology to tweet
about it
but
i think it made a much better world but
it created a lot of new dangers
so
maybe you can speak to
when you have
when you kind of
stand at the
end of the road for uh building a really
solid reliable universal computer
um what are the possibilities that are
positive what are the possibilities that
are negative how can we minimize the
chance of the negative
yeah that's a really good question so
there's so many positive things from
drug discovery from supply chain
um uh stress
for basically enabling chemists to
basically build more productive in the
lab right well this isn't the computer
is not going to replace the chemist
there's going to be a moore's law of
molecules right there's going to be so
many more molecules we can design so
many more diseases we can cure so
chemists in the lab as researchers
that's better for science so they can
build a bunch of um
uh like they could do science at a much
more accelerated pace so it's not just
the development of drugs it's actually
like doing the basic understanding of
the science of drugs and the
personalization the cost of drugs right
now we're all living longer we're all
having more and more we know more about
our genomic development we know about
our
you know pre-determination and we might
be able to one dream i've got is like
imagine you know
you you you can work your genome
assistant tells you you're going to get
cancer in seven years time
and uh you have your personal computer
that cooks up the right molecule just
for you to cure it right that's a really
positive idea yeah the other thing is um
is when drugs so right now i think it is
absolutely outrageous
that not all of humanity has access to
medicine
and i think the computer might be able
to change that fundamentally because it
will disrupt the way things are
manufactured so let's stop thinking
about manufacturing in different
factories let's say that computers
clinical grade computers or drug grade
computers will be in facilities all
around the world and they can make
things on demand as a function of the
cost you know maybe people won't be able
to afford the latest and greatest patent
but maybe they'll be up we get the next
best thing and we'll basically
democratize
um make available drugs to everybody
that they need you know and you know
there's lots of
really interesting things there so i
think that's going to happen
i think that now let's take
the the negative
before we do that let's imagine what
happened to go back to a really tragic
accident a few years ago or not accident
an act of murder by that pilot on the i
think it's euro wings or swiss swings
off but what he did is the plane took
off
um he went to his pilot went to the
toilet he was a co-pilot he locked the
door
and then set the the autopilot the the
the um above the alps so you set the
altimeter or the the the descend height
to zero so the computer just took the
plane into the alps
now
i mean
that was such a tragedy that obviously
the guy was mentally ill but it wasn't
just a tragedy for him it was for all
the people on board but what if and i
was inspired by this am i thinking what
can i do to do
to to anticipate problems like this in
the computer had the had the software
and i'm sure boeing and airbus will be
thinking ah maybe i can give the
computer a bit more situational
awareness and whenever one some tries to
drop the height of the plane and it
knows it's above the alps or just say oh
no computer says no we're not letting
you do that
um of course he would have been out of
fine another way maybe fly it until it
runs out of fuel or something but you
know keep anticipating all the
large number of trajectories that can go
negative all those kinds of running into
the alps and try to
at least make it easy for the engineers
to build systems that protecting us that
yeah and and let's just think so what
are in the computer world right now with
kydl's let's just not think about what
i'm doing right now what i'm doing right
now is it's completely open right
everyone's going to know kai dl's maybe
playing with them making them more
easier and easier and easier but what
we're going to start to do
it makes sense to
encrypt
the kydl's in such a way you you let's
say you work for a pharmaceutical
company and you have a license to make a
given molecule or you get issued with a
license by the fda or your local
authority and they'll say right you're
licensed to do it here it is it's
encrypted and the kdl gets run so you
have a license for that instance of use
easy to do computer science has already
solved the problem so the fact that we
all trust online banking
right then right now then we can secure
it i'm 100 sure we can secure the
computer
and because of the way we have a many
you know it's like the same um
mapping problem that you to actually
reverse engineer a kdl will be as hard
as reverse engineering the encryption
key
you know brute force it will be cheaper
um to um to just actually buy the
regulated medicine and actually people
aren't going to want to then
make their own fake pharmaceuticals
because it'll be so cheap to do it will
drop the cost of access to drugs now
what will happen recreational drugs
people start saying well i want access
to recreational drugs
well it's going to be up to it's going
to accelerate that social discussion
that's happening in the u.s and canada
and the uk everywhere right because cost
goes down yes
access goes up giving cannabis thc to
some people who've got epilepsy isn't
literally forgive the term a no-brainer
because these poor people go from
seizures like every day to maybe
seizures just once every few months
so that's that's an interesting idea to
try to minimize the chance that it can
get into like the hands of individuals
like
terrorists or people that want to do
harm
now
with that kind of thing you're putting a
lot of power in the hands of
governments in the hands of institutions
and so then
emerge the kind of natural criticism you
might have with governments that
can sometimes use these for ill use them
as uh weapons of war not weapon not
uh tools of uh betterment
so um
and sometimes not just war against other
nations but war against its own people
as it has been done throughout history
well i'm thinking so there's another way
of doing a decentralized peer-to-peer
version
where
and what you have to do i'm not saying
you should adopt a blockchain but there
is a way of maybe taking kdl's and put
them on blockchain here's an idea let's
just say the way we do in my lab right
now is we we go to the literature we
take a uh a recipe to make a molecule
convert that to cardio and diligently
make it in the robot and validate it we
that so we that i would call mining
proof of work fruit of synthesis
right
for the synthesis yeah yeah but this is
cool because suddenly when you do when
you actually synthesize it you can get
the analytical data but there's also a
fingerprint in there of the impurities
that get carried across because you can
never make one something 100 pure that
fingerprint will allow you to secure
your kdl so what you do is encrypt those
two things so suddenly you can have
people out there mining and what you
could do perhaps
is do the type of thing we need to
basically look at the way that contact
tracing should have been done in covid
where people are given the information
so you've just been in contact with
someone covered you choose i'm not
telling you to stay at home you choose
right so now if we could imagine a
similar thing like you know you have got
access to these chemicals they will have
these effects you choose and publicize
it or maybe it's out somewhere i don't
know i'm not a policy maker on this and
what my job here is to not just make the
technology possible but to have it as
open as a discussion as possible with
people to say hey can we stop childhood
mortality of this technology and to
those benefits outweigh
the one-off where people might use it
for terrorism or people might use it for
recreational drugs chemify which is the
name of the entity will make this happen
i think we have we have some social
responsibilities as an entity to make
sure that we're not enabling people to
manufacture
personal drugs weapons at will and what
we have to do is have a discussion with
society
with the people invest in this with
people that are going to pay for this
to say well do you want to live longer
and you want to be healthier
and are you willing to accept some of
the risks and i think that's a
discussion to have so by the way when
you say personal drugs
do you mean the illegal ones or do you
have a concern of just putting the
manufacturer of any kind of
legal drugs in the hands of
of uh
regular people because they might like
dose matters they might take way too
much i mean i would say to be honest the
either the chances of computers being
well shouldn't always never so the fact
i can now say this means it's totally
going to come true right you know i am
going to do it i i cannot imagine that
computers will be in people's houses
anytime soon but they might be at the
local pharmacy okay right and they and
if you've got a drug manufacturing
facility in every town
then you just go and they give you a
prescription they do it in such a way
they format it so that you you don't
have to take 10 pills every day you get
one manufactured for you that has all
the materials you need and the right
distribution got it but you mentioned
recreational drugs and and the reason i
mentioned because i know people are
going to
speak up on this if the drug is legal
there's to me no reason why you can't
manufacture
i mean for recreation i mean you can do
it what do you have against fondly
i
i haven't so i mean i'm a chemistry
professor in a university who who's an
entrepreneur as well i just think i need
to be as responsible as i can in the
discussion sure um not sure but i know
i'm so let me be the one that says like
there's nothing because you have said
recreational drugs and like terrorism in
the same sentence yeah yeah i think okay
i think let's make sure we draw a line
uh that there's
real dangers to the world of terrorists
of bio warfare and then there's a little
bit of weed so
i have i mean i i think it's up to the
society to yes to tell is governments
what it wants what's acceptable right
and if it becomes let's say that thcs
become
you know heavily acceptable and that you
can modify them so let's say there's
let's say it's like blood type there's a
particular type of thc that you that you
tolerate better than i do
then why not why not have a machine that
makes the one you like yeah and then and
why not the perfect brownie okay and i i
think that that's fine um
but i'm you know i we're so far away
from that i can barely get the thing to
work in the lab right i mean it's
reliability and all this other stuff but
what i think is going to happen in the
short term it's going to turbo charge
molecular discovery reliability and that
will change the world that's super
exciting
you have a draft of a paper titled
autonomous intelligent exploration
discovery and optimization of
nanomaterials
so we are talking about automating
engineering of nanomaterials
how hard is this problem
and as we continue down this thread of
the positives
and the worrisome
what are the things we should be excited
about
and what are the things we should be
terrified about and how do we minimize
the chance of the
of the uh terrifying consequences
so in this robot the robot does all the
heavy lifting so the robot basically
is an embodied ai i really
i really like ai in in in a domain
specific way one that actually should
say at this point there was an attempt
in the 60s uh joshua ludenberg and some
really important people did this that
made an ai
to try and guess if organic molecules in
a mass spectrometer were alien or not
yes
and they did they failed because they
didn't have assembly theory
i think and when i and i and wait what
does assembly theory give you about
alien versus human life well no it just
they it tells you about unknown the
degree of unknowns you can fingerprint
stuff they weren't looking at um they
were trying to basically just look at
the corpus of or complex organic
molecules
so i when i was a bit down about
assembly theory because i couldn't
couldn't convince referees and couldn't
convince computational
um
people interested in computational
complexity i was really quite depressed
about it and i mean i've been working
with with sarah walker's team
and i think she you know i think she
also invented an assembly theory in some
way we talk about it later
when i found the ai not working for
the dendral project
i suddenly realized i wasn't it totally
insane
coming back to this nano
robot so what it does it's a basically a
like a computer but now what it does is
it squirts
a liquid with gold in it in the test
tube
and it adds
um some
uh reducing agents there's some
electrons to make the gold turn into a
nanoparticle now when gold becomes a
nanoparticle it gets a characteristic
color a plasmon so it's a bit like if
you look at the sheen on a gold wedding
ring or a gold bar or something those
those are the ways that conducting
electrons basically reflect light
what we did is we randomly squirt the
gold the gold particle and the reducing
agent in and we measure the uv we
measure the color
and so what we do is we've got the robot
has a mind so it has a mind where
in a simulation
it randomly generates nanoparticles and
the plasmon the color that comes out
randomly generally imagines in its head
it then or the other so that's the
imaginary side of the robot in the
physical side of the robot it squirts in
the chemicals and looks at the color and
it uses a genetic algorithm and a map
elite actually on it and it goes around
in cycles and refines
um
the color to the objective
now we use two different points we have
an exploration
and an optimization they're two
different so the exploration just says
just do random stuff and see how many
different things you can get and when
you get different things try and
optimize and make the peak sharper
sharper sharper
and what it does after a number of
cycles is it physically takes a sample
of the optimized nano material
resets all the round bottom flasks
cleans them and puts the seed physical
seed back in
and what this robot is able to do is is
search a space of 10 to the 23 possible
reactions
in just a thousand experiments in three
days
and it makes five generations of
nanoparticles which get nicer and nicer
in terms of shape and color and
definition and then at the end it
outputs like ideal code
that could then be wow just doing the
search
for programs in the physical space yeah
so it's doing a kind of reinforcement
learning
yeah yeah in the physical space with the
exploration and the optimization and
that cardio will work on any computer or
any qualified hub now that's it that's
now that's a general piece of code that
can
replicate uh somewhat maybe perfectly
what it created that's amazing that's
incredible but the nanoparticles
themselves are dumb the robot has all
the thinking so we don't try and apply
any self-replication or try and get the
the particles to make themselves
although it would be cool to try so well
there you go that's that those are
famous last words for the end of human
civilization would be cool to try so is
it possible to create
molecules that start approaching this
question
that we started this conversation which
which is the origin of life so to start
to create molecules that have
life-like qualities so
have the replication have like complex
start to create complex organisms so we
have done this with the oxides i talked
about earlier the molybdenum oxides and
the rings and the bulls
and the problem is that well they are
they do
they auto catalytically enhance one
another so they would
i guess you would call it
self-replication but because there's
limited
um
function and mutation
they're pretty dumb so don't do very
much
so
i think
the prospect of us being able to
engineer
a nano material a nanomaterial life form
in the short term like i said earlier my
aim is to do this of course i mean i'm
you know on one hand i'm saying it's
impossible on the other hand saying i'm
doing it so which is it lee you know
it's like
uh well like i think we can do it but
only in the robot so the causal chain
that's gonna allow it's in the robot
these particles if they do start to
self-replicate the systems can be so
fragile
that i don't think anything
dangerous will come out it doesn't mean
we shouldn't treat them as potentially
you know
um
i mean i don't want to scare people like
gain a function we're going to produce
stuff that comes out our number one kill
switch is that we always try to search
a space of
objects that
don't exist in our reaction don't exist
in the environment so even if something
got out it just would die immediately
it's like making a silicon life form or
something or you know
which is the opposite of uh oftentimes
gain and function research just focused
on like how do you get a dangerous thing
to be closer to something that works
with humans yeah so have it jump to
humans so that's the one that's one good
mode to operate on is
always try to operate on
chemical entities that are very
different than the the kind of chemical
environment that humans operate in yeah
and also i mean i'll say something
dramatic
which may not be
may not be true so i should be careful
if let's say we did discover a new
living system but it was made out of a
shadow biosphere
and we just released it in the
environment who cares it's going to use
different stuff
it'll just live
just live yeah i i found one of my
biggest fantasies is actually is like a
planet
that's basically half in the sun it
doesn't rotate right and
and
you have two different origins of life
on that planet
and they don't share the same chemistry
yeah and then they only wait time they
recognize each other when they become
intelligent they go well what's that
moving yeah
i i wanted to co-evolve and that's
fascinating i mean so one fascinating
thing to do is exactly what you were
saying which is a life bomb
which is like
try to focus on atmospheres or
chemical conditions of other planets and
try within
this kind of
uh exploration optimization system try
to discover
life forms
that can work in those conditions and
then you send those life forms over
there
see what kind of stuff they build up
like you can do like a large scale
it's kind of a safe
physical environment to do large-scale
experiments it's another planet yeah so
look i'm gonna say something quite
contentious i mean elon wants to go to
mars i think it's brilliant wants to go
mars but i would counter that and say
is elon just obsessed with getting
humanity off earth or what about just
technology so if we do technology so so
elon either needs to take a computer to
mars he needs to manufacture drugs right
on demand right because zero cost
payload and all that stuff is just code
or what we do is we actually say hang on
it's quite hard for humans to survive on
mars
why don't we write a series of origin
life algorithms where we put our embed
our culture in it right this is a very
ridley spot prometheus right yeah which
is a terrible film by the way but anyway
um and dump it on mars and just
terraform mars and what we do is we
evolve life on mars that is suited to
life on mars yeah rather than brute
forcing human life on mars so one of the
questions is
you know what what is human culture what
is the things you encode some of it is
knowledge some of it is information
but the thing that elon talks about and
i think the thing i think about i think
you think about as well is
some of the more unique aspects of
human nature of what makes us human
which is our particular kind of
consciousness so he talks about the
flame of human consciousness
yeah that's one of the questions is can
we um
instill consciousness into other beings
because that's a sad thought
that whatever this thing inside our
minds that hopes and dreams and fears
and loves
can all die
yeah but i think you already know the
answer to that question
um i have a robot lawnmower at home my
kids call it cc call cutter it's a
robomow
and it the way it works it has an
electric field around the perimeter and
it just tell it the area and it
it goes out and goes from its base
station just mows a bit gets to the
perimeter detects and then chooses a
random angle rotates around and goes on
yeah
but my kids call it call cutter it's a
she i don't know why it's a she they
just they when they were like quite
young they called it
um i don't want to be sexist there it
could be but they liked um
they they gendered the lawnmower they
gendered the lawnmower okay yeah why not
but i was thinking this lawnmower
if you apply integrated information
theory to lawmaker the lawnmower is
conscious
now information integrated information
theory
um is that people say as a flawed way of
measuring consciousness but i don't
think it is i think assembly theory
actually measures consciousness in the
same way consciousness is something that
has generated over a population of
objects of humans
consciousness didn't suddenly spring in
our consciousness has evolved together
right the fact we're here and the robots
we leave behind
they all have some of that so we won't
lose it all
sure consciousness requires that we have
many models being generated there's not
just one domain specific ai right i
think that the way it created
consciousness i'm going to say
unashamedly the best way chemical to
make a consciousness is in a chemical
system because you just have access to
many more states
and the problem right now we're making
silicon consciousness
is you just don't have enough states so
there are more possible states or sorry
there are more possible configurations
possible in your brain than there are
atoms in the universe and you can you
can switch between them
you can't do that on a core i10 it's got
it's got 10 billion 12 billion 40
billion transistors but you can't you
can't reconfigure them as dynamically
well you've shared this intuition a few
times already that the larger number of
states
somehow correlates to greater
possibility of life but
it's also possible that constraints are
essential here yeah yeah i mean but but
coming back to the you worry that
something's lost i agree um
but i think that um
you know we will get to an agi
but i wonder if it's if it's not
it can't be separate from human it can't
be separate from human consciousness
because the causal chain that produced
it came from humans so the people what i
kind of try and suggest heavily to
people worry about
um the existential threat of ai saying
i mean you put it much more elegantly
earlier like we should worry about
algorithms on dumb algorithms written by
human beings on twitter driving us
insane right
and doing acting in odd ways
yeah i think intelligence this is what i
have been ineloquent in trying to
describe it
partially because
i try not to think
too deeply through this stuff because
then you become a philosopher i still
aspire to actually building a bunch of
stuff
but my sense is super intelligence
leads to um
deep integration into human society so
like
intelligence is strongly correlated like
uh
intelligence the way we conceive of
intelligence
materializes as a thing
that becomes a fun
entity to have at a party and
with humans so like uh it's a mix of wit
intelligence humor like intelligence
like knowledge ability to do uh
reasoning and so on but also
humor emotional intelligence ability to
love
to uh to dream to share those dreams
to um
to play the game of um human
civilization the push and pull the whole
dance of it the whole dance of life and
i think that kind of super intelligent
being
is not the thing that
that worries me i think that ultimately
will enrich life
it's again the dumb algorithms the dumb
algorithms that scale
in the hands of people that are too
don't study history that don't study
human psychology and human nature just
applying too broadly
for selfish near-term interests that's
the biggest danger yeah i think it's not
a new danger right um right i now know
how i should use twitter and how i
shouldn't use twitter right
um i like to provoke people into
thinking i don't want to provoke people
into outrage it's not fun it's not a
good thing for humans to do right
and i think that when you get people to
outrage they take sides
and taking sides is really bad but i
think that we're all beginning to see
this and i think that actually
i'm very optimistic about how things
will evolve because
you know
i wonder how much
how much productivity has twitter and
social media has taken out humanity
because how many now um
i mean so the good thing about twitter
is it gives power so it gives voice to
minorities right and and that's good to
some degree
but i wonder how much
voice does it give to
all sorts of other
problems that don't need this emergency
by the way when you say minorities i
think
uh
or at least if i were to agree with you
what i would say minorities broadly
defined in these small groups
of
people that
uh it magnifies
the concerns of the small versus the big
that is good to some degree
um but i think
i mean i have to be careful because i
think i have a a very
i mean i think that the world isn't that
broken right i think the world is pretty
cool place i think academia is really
great i think
climate change presents a really
interesting problem for humanity that we
will solve i like how you said it's a
pretty cool problem
for civilization it's a big one what's
the budget i want to there's a bunch of
really yeah really big problems that if
solved can
significantly improve the quality of
life or large that ultimately is what
we're trying to do
improve like how awesome life is for the
maximum number of people yeah and i
think the the coming back to
consciousness i don't think the human
universe is doomed to heat death right
it's one of the optimists that's why i
want to kind of nudge you into thinking
that time is fundamental because the
time is fundamental then suddenly
you don't have to give it back
the univ the universe just constructs
stuff you know and what we see around us
in our construction i know everyone's
worried about how fragile civilization
is and i mean look at the fundamentals
we're the good we're good until the
earth the the sun expands right
we've got quite a lot of resource on
earth we're trying to be quite
cooperative humans are nice to each
other
when they
when they're not under
enormous stress we're coming back to the
consciousness thing are we going to send
human beings to mars or conscious robots
to mars or are we going to send some
hybrid
um and our and i don't know the answer
to that question right now i guess you
know elon's gonna have a pretty good go
at getting there i'm not sure whether
i have my i have my doubts but i'm not
qualified you know i'm sure people have
their doubts that computation works yeah
but but but i've got it working and i
you know and most most of the cool
technologies we have today
and take for granted
like the airplane aforementioned
airplane were things that people doubted
every like majority of people doubted
before they uh came to life yeah and
they come to life and speaking of hybrid
ai and humans
it's fascinating to think about all the
different ways that
hybridization that merger can happen i
mean we have currently have the
smartphone so there's already a hybrid
but there's all kinds of ways that
hybrid happens how we and other
technology play together like a computer
how that changes
the fabric of human civilization is like
wide open who knows who knows if you
remove
if you remove cancer
if you remove major diseases
from humanity
there's going to be a bunch of
consequences we're not anticipating
many of them positive
but many of them negative
many of them most of them at least i
hope are weird and wonderful and and fun
in ways that are totally unexpected and
we sitting on a porch with a bottle of
jack daniels and a rocker we'll see
kids these days don't appreciate how
hard we had it back in the day i gotta
ask you um
speaking of nudging
you and uh yoshi bach
nudge each other on twitter quite a bit
in uh
wonderful intellectual debates
and of course for people who don't know
joshua bach is this brilliant guy he's
been on the podcast a couple times
you tweeted
or he to he tweeted joshua bach everyone
should follow him as well should
definitely follow mr lee cronin dr lee
cronin
um he tweeted dinner with lee cronin we
discussed that while we can translate
every working model of existence into a
turing machine
the structure of the universe might be
given by wakes of non-existence in a
pattern generated by all possible
automata which exists by default
and then he followed on saying face to
face is the best
so the the dinner was face to face what
is joshua talking about uh in wakes
quote wakes of non-existence in a
pattern generated by all possible
automata
which exists by default
so
automa exists by default
apparently
and then there's wakes of non-existence
what the hell is the non-existence in
the universe that's the top that's
and also in another conversation
you tweeted it's state machines all the
way down
which presumably is the origin story of
this discussion yeah and then joshua
said
again nudging nudging
nudging slash trolling
joshua said you've seen the light
welcome friend
many foundational physicists effectively
believe in some form of hyper
computation
lee is coming around to this idea and
then you said
i think there are notable differences
first i think the universe does not have
to be a computer second i want to
understand how the universe emerges
constructors that build computers and
third is that there is
uh something below church touring
okay
what the heck is this dinner
conversation about
uh maybe and put another way
maybe zooming out a little bit are there
interesting agreements or disagreements
between you and and joshua bach that uh
that can elucidate some of the other
topics we've been talking about
yeah so yash has an incredible mind and
he has he's so well read
um and
uses language really elegantly it
bamboozles me at times so i'm
uh so often i'm using i'm describing
concepts in a way that
i built from the ground up and so we
misunderstand each other a lot and he's
floating in in the clouds
something like not quite but i think so
this concept of a turing machine so a
turing machine turing machines
i would argue
um and i think um this is not
the turing machine the universe is not a
turing machine
biology is not even a turing machine
right and because turing machines don't
evolve right there's a there is this
problem that people see chewing machines
everywhere but isn't it interesting the
universe gave rise to biology that gave
rise to intelligence that gave rise to
alan turing who invented the abstraction
of the turing machine and allowed us to
digitize
and
and so
i've been looking for the mystery at the
origin of life the origin of
intelligence and the origin of this and
i when i discuss with yasha i think
yoshi he was saying well the universe of
course the universe is a turing machine
of course there's a there's a hyper
computer there and i've and i think we
got kind of trapped in our words and
terms
because of course it's possible for a
turing machine or computers to exist in
the universe we have them
but what i'm trying to understand is
where did the transition continuous to
discrete occur
and i've been this is because of my
my general foolishness of understanding
um
the continuous
but
i guess what i'm
trying to say is
there were constructors before they were
abstractors
because
how did the universe abstract itself
into existence
and it goes back to earlier saying could
the universe intelligence have come
first what's the constructor what's an
abstractor so the abstractor is the
ability of say
of alan turing and goodall and very and
and church
to in to think about the mathematical
universe
and to label things
and then from those labels to come up
with a set of axioms
with those labels
and to basically understand the universe
mathematically and say okay i can label
things
but where did the labeler come from
where is the prime labeler even if the
universe
is not
a touring computer
does that negate the possibility that a
touring computer can simulate the
universe like just because the
abstraction was formed at a later time
does that mean that abstraction this is
to our cellular automata conversation
yeah you were taking away some of the
magic from the cellular automata because
very intelligent biological systems came
up with that cellular automata well this
is where the existence is the default
right is it does the fact that we exist
and we can come up with a turing machine
does that mean the universe
has to be a turing machine as well
but
can it be a touring machine though
that's a
that has to be in the canopy can it be
sure
um
i don't know i don't understand if it
has to be or not can it be
but can the universe have
turing machines in it sure they do exist
now
i'm wondering though
maybe and this is this is written if
things get really hairy
is i think the universe maybe in the
past did not have the computational
power that it has now
this
this is almost like a
law of physics kind of
so the
computational power is not
you can get some free lunch yeah i mean
with the fact that we now we sit here in
this period in time and we can imagine
all these robots and all these machines
and we built them and so we can easily
imagine going back in time that the
universe was capable of having them but
i don't think it can
so the universe may have been a lot
dumber computationally and i think
that's why i don't want to go back to
the time discussion but i think it has
some relationship with it the universe
is basically smarter now than it used to
be and it's going to continue getting
smart smarter over time because of
novelty generation and the ability to
create objects within objects within
objects you know there's a perhaps it's
grounded in physics there's this
intuition of conservation
yeah that stuff is conserved like like
you're not you've always had all
everything
you're just rearranging books on the
bookshelf
through time
so you're saying like new books are
being written which laws you want to
break the origin of the origin of the
big bang
you had to break the second law because
we got order for free yeah
well what i'm telling now is that the
energy isn't conserved in the universe
oh it's the second law okay i got you so
because but not in a mad way okay so
computation
potentially is not conserved which is a
fascinating idea
intelligence
is not conserved
complexity is not conserved
i suppose that's deeply connected to uh
time being fundamental
the natural consequence of that
is if time is fundamental
and the universe is inflating in time
if you like
then there are one or two conservation
laws that we need to have a look at and
i wonder if that means the total energy
of the universe is actually increasing
over time
and i might this may be completely
ludicrous but
um we do have all this dark energy
that's we we have some anomalies let's
say dark matter and dark energy if we
don't add them in
galaxies so dark matter i think doesn't
doesn't hold
you know you need to hold the galaxies
together and there's some other
observational issues could dark energy
just be time
so figuring out what dark energy is
might give us some
uh deep clues about this
not just time but the consequences of
time so it could be that i mean i'm not
saying there's perpetual motions allowed
in this free lunch but i'm saying
if the universe is intrinsically
asymmetric
and it appears to be
um
and it's generating novelty and it
appears to
um couldn't that just be a
mechanistically how reality works
and therefore
um i don't
really like this idea that the and so i
want to live in a deterministic universe
that is
undetermined yeah right the only way i
can do that so time is fundamental
because otherwise it's all the rest of
us just it's just slight of hand because
the physicist will say yes everything's
deterministic
newton is
newtonian mechanics it's deterministic
quantum mechanics is deterministic let's
take the everedian view
and then basically we can just draw out
this massive universe branching but it
closes again we get it all back and
don't worry your feeling of free will is
effective
what the physicists are actually saying
is the entire future is mapped out and
that is clearly
problematical
and clearly
um
that's not so clear yeah it's just it's
just problematic it well
yeah yeah so it's it's okay because that
maybe is just the way it is it's
problematic to you well creature along
this timeline i want to reduce the
number of beliefs i need to understand
the universe
so if time is fundamental i don't need
to have magic order at the beginning and
i don't need a second law but you do
need the magical belief that time is
fundamental well i need the i need the
observation that i'm seeing to be just
like how it is all the way down but the
earth also looks flat
if you cut if you agree
with your observation so we can't
necessarily trust our observation i know
the earth isn't flat because i can send
a satellite into space
but i'm saying i'm going to do
experiments that start to show
i mean i i think that it's worth so
if you can't so if i cannot do an
experiment or a thought experiment
that will test this assumption then the
assumption is without merit really in
the end
you know that's it's fine yeah so that's
a beautiful idea you hold yourself to
that's that's uh that's
given that you think deeply in a
philosophical way
you think about some of these really
important
issues and you have theoretical
frameworks like
uh assembly theory
it's really nice that you're always
grounded with experiment
that's what i have that's so refreshing
that's so beautifully refreshing
now
that we're holding you to the ground in
an experiment to the harsh truth of
reality let me ask the the big
ridiculous question
what is the meaning of this whole thing
what's the meaning of life why
this uh
time is fundamental it's marching
forward
and along this
long timeline come along a bunch of
descendants of apes
that uh have come up with cellular
automata and computers and now computers
why
i have so many different answers to this
question it depends on on what day
i would say that given the way of the
conversation we had today i'd say the
meaning
well we make our own meaning i think
that's fine but i think the universe
wants to
explore every possible configuration
that this allows us to explore
and this goes back to the kind of
question that we were asking about yasha
and the existence and non-existence of
things right so if the universe is a
turing machine it's churning through a
load of states
and you think about combinatorial theory
before assembly theory so everything is
possible
what yahshua and i were saying is
well not everything is potent
we don't see the commentary explosion we
see something else
and what we see is um
evidence of memory
so there's there clearly seems to be
some interference between
the commentary explosion of things and
what the universe allows
and it's like this kind of constructive
destructive interference
so maybe the universe is not just about
um
it is assembling objects in space and
time and those objects are able to
search more
um space and time and the universe is
just infinitely creative and i guess
i'm searching for why the universe is
infinitely creative or is it infinitely
creative and maybe the meaning is just
simply to make as many objects create as
many things as possible
and i and i see a future of the universe
that doesn't result in the heat death of
the universe the universe is going to
extract every ounce of creativity it can
out of it because that's what we see on
nerf right and if you think that
almost like intelligence is not
conserved that maybe creativity isn't
either maybe like
it's an infinite well so like creativity
is ultimately tied to novelty
you're coming up with cool new
configurations of things and maybe that
just can continue indefinitely
and uh this human species that was
created along the way is probably just
one method like that's able to ask
the universe about itself it's just one
way to explore creativity maybe there's
other meta levels on top of that
like obviously as a collective
intelligence will create organisms maybe
there'll be organisms that
uh
ask themselves questions about
themselves
in uh in a in a deeper bigger picture
way that we humans do first to ask
questions about the humans and then
construct some kind of
hybrid systems that ask themselves about
the collective aspect just like some
weird stacking that we can't even
imagine yet and that's stacking i mean
i've discussed this stacking a lot with
um with sarah walker who's a professor
of physics and
astrobiology at asu
and we argue about you know how creative
the universe is going to be and is it as
deterministic as all that because i
think she thinks she's more of a free
will thinker and i'm of a less free will
thinker but i think we're beginning to
converge and understanding that um
because there's simply a missing
understanding right now we don't we
don't understand how the universe we
don't know what rules the universe has
to allow the universe to contemplate
itself so asking the meaning of it
before we know even know what those
rules are is premature but my guess is
that it's not meaningless and it isn't
just about that and there's there are
three levels of meanings obviously the
universe wants us to do stuff we're
interacting with each other so we create
meaning in our own society and our own
interactions for human humanity but i do
think there is something else going on
but because reality is so weird
we're just scratching at that and i
think that we have to make the
experiments better and we have to
perhaps
join across not just for the
computational lists and what i try to do
with yahshua is meet him halfway so what
happens if i become a computationalist
what do i gain a lot it turns out
because i can make turing machines in
the universe because on the one hand i'm
making computers which are state
machines inspired by turing on the other
hand i'm saying they can't exist
well clearly that's that i can't have my
cake and eat it so there's something
that weird going on there so then did
the universe have to make a continuous
to a discrete transition or is the
universe just discrete it's probably
just discrete
so if it's just discrete then there are
i will then give yasha his
turing-like property in the universe but
maybe there's something else below it
which is the constructor that constructs
a turing machine that then constructs
you know it's a bit like the
you you generate an a computing system
that then is able to build an
abstraction that then recognizes
it can make a generalizable abstraction
because human beings with mathematics
have been not going to be able to go on
and build physical computers if that
makes any sense
and i think that's the meaning i think
that's you know as far as we can the
meaning will be further elucidated with
further experiments
well you mentioned sarah i think uh you
and sarah walker are just these uh
fascinating human beings i'm really
fortunate
to um have the opportunity to be in your
presence to study your work to follow
along with your work i'm big i'm a big
fan
like i told you offline i hope we get a
chance to talk again with perhaps just
the two of us but also sarah that's a
fascinating dynamic uh
uh for people who haven't heard i
suppose on clubhouses where i heard you
guys talk but you have an incredible
dynamic and i also can't uh wait to hear
you and joshua talk so i think if
there's some point in this uh
predetermined or yet to be determined
future
uh where the the three of us
you and sarah or the four of us with
yosha could meet and talk would be a
beautiful future and i look i look i
look forward to most features but i look
forward to that one in particular lee
thank you so much for spending your
valuable time with me today thanks lex
it's been a pleasure
thanks for listening to this
conversation with lee cronin to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from the mad scientists rick sanchez of
rick and morty fame
to live
is to risk it all
otherwise you're just a an inner chunk
of randomly assembled molecules
drifting wherever the universe blows you
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you